there's no time 13 o clock hey you guys
it's us again and it's episode 199 199
yeah that means we gotta do [ __ ] 200
next week holy crap I have like totally
not even prepared for that obviously I
have so much other kind of crap like the
livestream that I imagine we probably
should I mean we'll probably do it cuz
we usually record these on Fridays so we
might we might live stream at Friday
night or maybe Saturday night I'm not
really sure and then I can actually put
up the put it up Tuesday on the regular
time for people that didn't see it so I
don't know I'm thinking about cuz I
still have to like test how it's gonna
work out with my computer and everything
like that because you know computers
like really old that we use so I'm not
really sure how it's gonna work out so
we'll have to do some tests this
upcoming week before we do it but yeah
so on this episode though going back to
the true crime now this is a topic that
has been requested multiple times and I
actually did probably I mean I do a lot
of research for most of the other shows
but this one I probably did more than
any other show just because there is so
much content about this I mean there are
books there are multiple documentaries
there's news stories there's just all
kind of stuff and I watched as much of
it as I could and read through as much
that I could I've watched all the
document as I watched you know west of
Memphis the 2012 documentary I watched
the original documentaries from HBO
Paradise Lost
I read excerpts from the books of some
of the people and everything like that
so hopefully I don't have like so much
information rattling around in my brain
that I just like lockup and forget what
the book I was talking about cuz that
does happen some we could always hit a
dash it out I know but it's like it's
editing it just makes it take longer
it's like it so I always like try not
really serious out we very rarely edit
anything on this show a lot you know
that's why this live stream I don't
really give a [ __ ] about a live stream
yeah it won't really make much this
shows you've been watching or pretty
much just a live stream I mean like I
said generally the only time I will take
something out is if I completely spaced
and like lose my place in my notes or I
forget them and I'm just like or if he
has to pay that's like pretty much the
only because he'll be like pause it and
then I'll run off to the bathroom your
life to him I'm just gonna get up yeah
part of the show I got a leak you could
probably just say my dad's voice I got a
legal for the live stream maybe we
should both were adult diapers like an
astronaut [ __ ] their [ __ ] pants well
what else you got is basic it's like you
can't climb out of the spacesuit man
it's like you know that's gonna be a
huge pain in the ass but yeah so yeah so
today in case I didn't mention it we are
talking about the West Memphis Three
case now like I said I did a massive
amount of research on this and because
it's very complex and there's just so
many tendrils and everything
now I'm gonna say right from the outset
spoiler alert I am of the opinion as
most people are although I know that
there are some on the in the other camp
as well that the three people that were
convicted of the murders didn't do it
I'm pretty sure that they were innocent
like I'm probably 98% sure that they
didn't do it um like I said I know
they're released yet they have been
released but it took they were in prison
for 18 years damn who's very lawsuit no
and I'll get into why that was later on
I'd sue your [ __ ] ass off there well
they could in two years they couldn't
because it was like a yeah I'll get into
that but that yeah there was a reason
why they didn't but yeah nothing like it
yeah like I said I'm sure there's gonna
be people there like well what about
this and what about that because you
know all the [ __ ] that I watched online
because on YouTube they had they have
west of Memphis which was the one the
2012 documentary that was produced by
Peter Jack
Lord of the Rings fame who kind of got
involved with the case early on and like
gave them money and stuff that it's kind
of a case where I was I was reading all
this stuff and I was watching all these
news reports and interviews with Damien
Echols who was one of the guys that was
convicted and there's one guy in
particular I can't remember what his
YouTube handle is but pretty much every
video that's about the West Memphis
Three this guy will come on and I'm sure
he'll probably come on this one as well
um in saying it's like oh they were
guilty and what about this and what
about that and what about the other
thing but the thing I was reading
through some of his stuff and I was just
kind of like well a lot of the stuff
that he says made them guilty wasn't
true like a lot of it was just like
rumors or [ __ ] that they found out later
wasn't the case remember the guy's name
who does this
it was CMS or justice or some handle
like that but every single video that I
watched about this and it was a lot that
guy had to come on and like so he takes
it he takes the debunking of the case
Andry bunks it it's a Reebok sorry bunk
I think you just coined a new word
that's a grief um that's a word like
they need yeah because that's like
someone that something has been debunked
for example you know flat earth oh yeah
yeah which has been debunked obviously
like hundreds of years ago but people
that are in the flat Earth's they're
gonna read book that's free they're
gonna take all the debunking there and
they're gonna use it to like three bunk
this yeah that's you heard it here first
yeah and so that's yeah I don't think
I've ever heard that term before so
that's actually a really good one
there's that right there man we need to
have so many shirts but yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna come out and say that I'm
probably with the majority on this that
I think that that the three people that
were convicted were innocent in which
case you know it's horrible enough that
three little boys got killed like in the
original crime but then these three KITT
who were teenagers at the time that they
were convicted their lives
got pretty royally [ __ ] as well and
I'm pretty sure I'm not gonna say a
hundred percent that I think I know who
did it
but I have my suspicions and that person
is still
walking around loose so that's also not
good so we'll get into it you know I'll
get into all the [ __ ] here but um we got
a couple of shout outs got a couple
PayPal donations this week one of them
was from our good friend Melanie who
sends this one every now and again like
usually once a month or thereabouts so
thank you very much Melanie we also got
a new person of sending us a PayPal
donation named Amanda Amanda oh I have a
resume yeah you're and it's yeah she had
a New Age stuff I was looking at her
little girls in the New Age I think so
she because she asked on YouTube like
what the link was but then she figured
out like where yeah I think I check to
see who that was she's got a couple
videos on like New Age [ __ ]
philosophies and [ __ ] like that
yeah okay that's cool yeah so thank you
very much Amanda also we had one of our
patrons who before had to leave for
whatever reason creepy crepes has
returned this week so thank you very
much for coming back like I said it's
really nice to have you back again and I
understand that like you know things are
tough all over and you know we're not
gonna be mad like if you can't tribute
anymore and stuff like that because like
I said everybody's having a rough time
South world's [ __ ] you flying apart and
you heard it here first I [ __ ]
predicted yeah but you always think
that's gonna happen my nature it's part
of my nature but I can tell you the
order that it's gonna [ __ ] fall apart
the next thing that's gonna happen
eventually if it's not stopped will be
an attack on the power grid that's don't
give anybody any ideas they already know
well ya know they already know don't
encourage I'm looking at I'm looking
online and watching them talking about
it yeah well yeah that would not be good
yeah that way
there goes everyone's livelihood cuz if
you attack the power grid well they're
doing it against people that they
consider to be their domestic enemies
kill the power grids and starve out
those cities that's what they want to do
yeah um what else oh I had one more
thing and I we should probably do like I
don't I don't know if I wanna do a whole
show about it again but um I had a
couple people that messaged me and said
that there has been a new development in
the Madeleine McCann case which we did a
show about a while back um I don't think
they've arrested the guy yet but they
have a guy like a new suspect
and they actually I don't think they've
named him they're just calling him
Christian b-but they did with the first
[ __ ] when it came out like they had him
like a picture of him but like his face
was blocked out but now they're showing
him so this is a German fella and he was
apparently he had gotten in trouble many
times before for a very straight child
you know abduction child you know sexual
things against children and stuff and he
had coincidentally been staying in that
area of Portugal prior to lose or
whatever it was called staying in a
house in that resort where Madeleine
McCann was taken from so apparently
they've been trying to build a case
against this guy for like years and they
didn't want to like announce anything
until they were sure that they had like
enough evidence to come out with it so
they just recently came out with a like
yesterday or the day before you know or
you know a few days ago a few days ago
can depending on when you listen to this
but um so we'll see where that goes I
mean because that does happen every now
and then where they come out they said
she's a big thing in the case and it's
like we think we caught the guy that did
it and stuff but then it kind of doesn't
go anywhere so like I said they have
been building a case against this guy
for a long time and it does sound like
he has the history a history of this
type of thing like he had been arrested
previously for breaking into like resort
you know condos and stuff in that area
and like stealing things so they think
maybe that he broke in to this house
maybe not even knowing that the kid was
in there and just like broke in to steal
something that saw the kid there and
took her so we don't know how that's
gonna go but a couple of you have sent
me links to that so I just wanted to
mention it on the show where this
happened again in Portugal okay remember
it was like a British couple and they
were vacationing there and they're
literally yeah they were eating dinner
like a few hundred yards away and they
put her to bed it was funny is that
there was there's a guy that was kind of
doing something similar to that in this
area in Florida he was a dude who would
just go into housing complexes and look
at the damn pool and if there was a
woman at the pool he jumped a fence if I
could pull a gun on her if I can take
care of into the foot and dressing room
rape her and then move on he was a
serial rapist yes he started doing that
I think that was in round I think I
first heard about it in 2010 it's here
in Florida
they caught the guy but they got him on
video well that's right get up they got
him on video just African American guy
just real nondescript young 20 yeah all
right you got a minute because of his
hairstyle and what he was wearing I mean
it could be anybody all right
you know I mean there's a generic look
for everybody this is a generic white
guy's generic black guy just kind of a
generic black guy you don't see his face
real clearly yeah just his build and his
clothes I mean it could be anybody
that's kind of the thing that I thought
when I looked at the picture of this guy
that they're looking at for the
Madeleine McCann I was like he just
looks like a generic white guy yeah just
generic like kind of a thin European
white guy I mean this kind of spiky hair
and blue eyes it's funny I mean people
just [ __ ] look like anybody well yeah
and I'll get a real close look at the
face it could just be anybody well
that's why I'm always like really um you
know and that's another thing too and we
might get into this a little bit when we
talk about the West Memphis Three case
that's why I'm always really really I
don't know it just seems like eyewitness
testimony you know that's good that's a
start but people I mean if I had if I
walked past a dude for example and then
later that dude did something and you
know somebody came back to me and said
can you describe him for sure probably
would not be able to yeah or I would
just have like a very cuz I don't like
stare at people's faces or like the
detail of him or anything like that if
they're not doing anything you know to
cause to catch my attention well they
usually ask you questions in a certain
order to try to get a description
because they know people are like that
right they ask you what race was he yeah
I mean it helped all was he you know and
then like what it is you know did he
have a long hair or short hair they
usually it's like a process of an
elimination yeah going through you know
what kind of clothes did he have and a
lot of times if the guy if the
questioning is done right you could get
pretty damn close yeah even if you think
you didn't get that good a look at them
yeah they ask you the right questions in
the right order the a good profiler can
come up with real close to who that was
they'll end up withdrawing and it's you
look back like after they catch the guy
go yeah it's pretty damn close
although the weird thing is that
sometimes too like when they have a
drawing or an identikit if you're in the
UK
of the suspect or of like a missing
person or somebody that like a dead
person that they found that's
unidentified and they'll like do a
drawing of them or like make a you know
cast or whatever and it's like sometimes
I look at them and I'm just like okay
but then they catch the person or they
match the dead person to a real identity
and it's a know some of them it doesn't
look anything like it and I'm like how
the [ __ ] did you get that from that I
don't like who it was because sometimes
like particularly in some of the cases
of I think we talked about this a little
bit the same Samuel little thing where
he would he drew like pictures of all of
his victims when they were trying to
like get all this information out of him
and one of the victims that they
identified like one of the relatives of
the woman that was missing had seen the
drawing and called the cops but then
when they identified the woman cuz they
did ID her through DNA and everything
like that and the identifiers it was
like she didn't really look that much
like the picture not enough that it
would that I'd be like hey that's my
aunt or that's my sister or whatever it
just wasn't close enough to me maybe if
you did know that person like maybe it
looked a lot closer to them it just
seemed really strange but some of them
are actually pretty close no Sam I've
seen that we're pretty close yeah some
of them though I'm just kind of like how
the hell did they identify them for that
because they one of the ones I
remembered is they had a drawing of a
girl um well [ __ ] had this [ __ ] go OK
they found a dead girl in a locker yeah
in an abandoned building this is
somewhere out in the southwest and she
had a long black hair and she had little
moccasins on she looked like she might
have been Native American oh I think I
read about that she was mummified in
there yeah and you could kind of see her
face but they made a drawing of what she
would look like when she was alive and
it looked [ __ ] perfect yeah you know
but they never could ID the woman
although that's not really that's not
really the same thing we're talking
about it's just that just came to mind
yeah at one case well are we good the
thing about it is that a good forensic
artist it's just like anything else it's
like you know forensic artists that's a
very very specialized yeah you have to
know like what that person would have
looked like just by looking at the bone
structure and you
you have to draw the seer face it was
mummified yeah showed a photograph of
her fan you know I mean because it's hot
and dry she didn't and she was in that
locker
maggots didn't get to her she didn't
like decompose
no she just dried up like a piece of
beef jerky yeah you know kind of like
those people that were sacrificed at
Mesoamerica some as you find it yeah
they've been up there for five hundred
years but they look like they were
killed last week yeah so that's what
like is really really creepy because
everyone just look like they're like
[ __ ] sleeping yeah back there
sleeping even though the bodies like
kinds of you know there was one that
they're working on that girl she's
probably prettiest out just said he
choked her to death in a sacrifice had
her up on a [ __ ] little look cliff on
a mountain no nothing can get to her
yeah and her clothes and everything or
two intact real finely braided hair and
stuff and she looks like she's just
sleeping it's weird that's what I mean
that's like super great what's up and I
think she's 500 years old that's [ __ ]
ridiculous man Jessica's because it was
super dry real high-altitude yeah yeah
yeah like you said if you're away from
like bugs and yeah maggots and stuff
like that or you're somewhere where it's
really arid and they should we just get
a lot of that and it was I think it was
cold she's just kind of freeze-dried
yeah yeah no well that particulars just
kind of turned into beef jerky yeah you
could see her face it didn't even look
disgusting
no they show a picture of it yeah and
then next to it a drawing what she
looked like when she was alive and it
just like just you can imagine like yeah
that's what she would look like yeah but
they don't think they ever ID'd that
girl they don't know who that is
it's sad I mean that happens a lot
because like I said when I do you know
research for my books and stuff I put
like a number of you know bodies of
unidentified victims almost always women
that you know they still like years and
years have gone by and they still don't
know who these women are and a lot of
times they just find them like on the
side of the road somewhere like in a
ditch or like buried in a shallow grave
lump-sum it's like you know by side of
highways cuz I think like truckers are
doing that kind of [ __ ] um sometimes
something yeah sometimes or they just
get I think in a lot of cases it's the
parents that kill them that's why the
parents aren't looking if it's children
yeah it may be or their parents are dead
or they or they dis disowned the
person because they killed the entire
family and the family yeah you never
know
I mean you never know they might be an
orphan for [ __ ] sake and I kept a
daughter for a while and then killed her
later I remember when they found that
girl she was sucking in a cardboard box
set on fire had some bullet holes in her
and she was dead that was done by the
mom yeah remember that one that psycho
ass mom well it's just kind of like um
you know it's kind of like whenever
someone is murder particularly like when
a woman is murdered most of the time it
is
you know husband boyfriend ex-boyfriend
you know stalk or something like that in
you know I'm just gonna pull a number
out of my ass but I mean you in at least
80% of cases and that's why they do them
that's usually somebody that goes for
yeah now I don't know how accurate this
is but when I was researching West
Memphis Three case I will say that when
children are killed fifty at least 50%
of the time fifty sixty percent of the
time one of the parents may have been
involved you know so it's just kind of a
thing where most people they get
murdered it's someone that they knew
yeah and I think that explains why
there's so many unclaimed bodies yeah I
don't know who that is
because nobody's looking for that body
right they're not looking for it you get
that because the parents are the ones
are the ones that did it or the or the
items are the ones that didn't that's a
lot of it not all of it yeah I think
that's a lot of it well and or sometimes
two particularly ones with you know
women that are just dumped and stuff a
lot of times I think maybe they were you
know sex workers or drug addicts or
Runaways or whatever
and then they just got picked up by the
wrong person and that person just killed
them and left them somewhere and and
maybe their families didn't even know
where they were didn't know where they
were because they were always gone and
then families and then a lot of times
people don't realize you know children
outlive their families a lot yeah Ashley
in the lower like I said maybe their
parents are dead their parents died and
a lot of times their parents die young
because they're coming out of a damn
troubled family or the parents were in
prison so they don't know where the kid
is yes that kind of stuff yeah but so um
like I said the thing about I just find
it [ __ ] I didn't mean to interrupt
you I just find it a trip that a person
could die and there's never even a
[ __ ] complaint the police don't even
know that the person was murdered I
don't find that night I don't nobody
looking at that person yeah it's just
that all its like it didn't even happen
because a lot of people just slip
between the cárdenas yeah it's just
funny because when you think about you
think well if I [ __ ] murdered this
person immediately they'll be sirens and
they'll [ __ ] beat cops and the SWAT
team will jump out of the [ __ ]
shadows and get you know not really
nope if you choose the if your
victimology if you choose the victim
correctly you can kill the person they
vanish and no one even knows the person
is missing well look at all the [ __ ] I
mean look at all the you know kind of
highway like the Texas killing field
some you know Colonial Parkway birds
look like all the [ __ ] that goes on like
up in Canada like all those indigenous
women that just kind of go missing and
stuff um you know like I said these are
a lot of times these are women that not
always but you know some of our sex
workers are there you know coming from
poverty or something like that and
they're a very vulnerable population so
if somebody is you know a serial killer
for example is you know hanging around
this community like preying on those the
first people they're gonna go after
because you know nine times out of ten
no one's gonna miss that person or
they're not gonna you know report that
person missing yeah which is sad but
that's I mean serial killers know that
[ __ ]
that's why they go after them those
women particularly not on Miss ISM right
so let's kind of okay so I did the shout
outs right so let's get into talking
about the West Memphis Three
case now okay so this all started in May
of 1993 in West Memphis Arkansas which
is um pretty small town very Bible Belt
you know which kind of will come into
play much later on because this is a
very as you'll see this is 1993 but this
was still very satanic panic time period
I remember the time because because I
think most people associate satanic
panic with the 80s but it actually went
well into the 90s especially in more
rural communities like in the United
States
um and that played a humongous factor in
this case and why these particular
teenagers were convicted I remember I
was buying Christian death albums and
[ __ ] from [ __ ] the local record
stores taking him back to Fort Campbell
and taking guys that are in the army
with her like what the [ __ ] was this
there was still a lot of like
yeah and this was nothing overs from the
satanic panic but I think most
reasonable people realized that that was
all [ __ ] by that time most not in
Arkansas they didn't know not in
Arkansas not in this part no there are
still people there were still people way
in the late 90s remember in Mississippi
up in Gulfport past Christian era and
Louisiana that still believed that that
[ __ ] happened yep that they were satanic
cults [ __ ] statue kids that never
happened
nope that was our first show on this
show was about the second one the second
one was about satanic patty you guys
haven't heard - oh go back Melissa we
should revisit that because I want to go
more into well I want to specifically I
think we mentioned it on that show I
haven't listened to it a long time but I
want to go back specifically and talk
about that Matt Martin recently are
veterans of the [ __ ] satanic panic we
were there I remember that [ __ ] that was
a model panic just kind of like the
moral panics of today and I think do it
throughout history man this [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes and goes
even like back in medieval times they
had [ __ ] weird outbreaks of [ __ ]
people dancing and dancing themselves
yeah and it's all this [ __ ] humans
are [ __ ] a hell of a drug [ __ ] are
crazy yeah yeah they're great
well they're very influenced by other
people yeah mass psychology mash panics
moral panics weird religious ideas
coming and going and the more you don't
know about [ __ ] like the more you invent
stuff and what they're inventing [ __ ]
and then it is this synergy and when I
say religion or not necessarily me it
doesn't necessarily mean [ __ ]
Abrahamic religions you have secular
religions and cults now they [ __ ]
believe weird [ __ ] some of them are
[ __ ] have a real corporate [ __ ]
face to them it seems like well it's got
to be official all you gotta do is look
at Scientology yeah
Scientology looks very official it's
very [ __ ] corporate if you didn't
know what you were dealing with you
might believe that well many of the
powerful corporations today like Google
and always they're using those same
techniques and it has to do with power
power and money well I bet that's where
l ron Hubbard got all that he got like
all that kind of like 50s clobber knew
what the [ __ ] he was doing man he was a
[ __ ] naval officer he's very
intelligent creative guy he could lies
ass no no no
crazy could he have been that
[ __ ] I've read a lot of his
writing like not really cuz I wanted to
he was very successful he was but he was
still a nut case you could be a nut case
yeah but it worked
yeah it worked he case in in a way that
was very beneficial to him right it was
very beneficial to him he was a powerful
cult leader and people liked him that's
not yeah to be honest - I think like I'm
not saying that Scientology wasn't
shitty and scary back then cuz it was
but I think it got a lot it got a lot
worse
it wasn't latest I'm under mascara I'm
very anti Scientology and we didn't she
done shows on it we had the anger gay
Pope on here but I got to admit during
the times of l ron hubbard the cultists
liked l ron hubbard he is nice and he
was a fair man he was a good man it was
a lot less problem it still problematic
but less problem a lot less they were
there willingly and he was [ __ ]
playing all these games and they were
having a good time it was a scene yeah
they were making money and yeah he was
[ __ ] weird and but he was a science
fiction writer and a dude [ __ ] and and
evidently everybody loved him he would
sit there and [ __ ] tell you about
what the aliens were doing on another
planets and taking out on a [ __ ] boat
and do you know you don't I mean she
know and and and and and one of the
weirdest things about Elrond is that he
was surrounded by beautiful young women
and he wasn't taking advantage of them
not that I ever heard of widows very
strange usually cult 101-101 is [ __ ]
those young girls and get mind-control
and he was you know I believe even
though he was cut he was crazy and he
didn't know it
he was bullshitting he was a man of
honor and I gotta give that to [ __ ] I
mean as far as I know I'm it's you know
what I mean almost every you would think
that it would have come here by now
everyone who is like that everyone who
was there that defected from the church
unanimously said no he was very
trustworthy around women yeah that women
were throwing themselves which like I
said that's very unusual very unusual
for usually that's the whole reason you
start a cult
yes sex drugs there's drugs and money's
usually what I mean 99 brought it
evidently young women were throwing
themselves at what make sense
usual he was weird yeah we're he was
aware young women were throwing
themselves at Al Ron and he was very
know nothing you know very
straight-laced and very yeah it's like
it that's so weird that I really have a
hard time believing it but I guess it's
true because I haven't ever heard
anything to the contrary the people that
defected from the cult the Barry
anti-scientology all confirmed that he
was actually a good man
yeah and that he did not take advantage
of women yeah which in a way is weird
that is very weird like I said because
that's cuz that's usually what that's
all about
that's usually the whole reason they
start off all right now is the new
leadership's not like that no not by
long yeah like I said it was weird
before but it's like after that guy took
over I think it just got worse and worse
and now it's just like a [ __ ] riot
with the soldiers but the thing is that
shit's original and a lot of stuff
you're hearing in the modern in the
modern zeitgeist of today you have to
understand this is corporate propaganda
and a lot of corporate propaganda
corporations are cults they're run like
cults because they're run like
militaries and militaries are like cults
I'm ex-military I've come from a warrior
cult I know what it is but just because
it's a cult doesn't mean it's bad
military cults run a certain way because
it has to what it's what its job is is
to do horrible things for a good outcome
you have to have cult-like [ __ ]
behavior to get that job done and that's
with everything every organization out
there has weird wit weird ways of doing
things
well yeah you have to achieve the
mission yeah so anyway let's get back
off that and get on this yeah it's like
I said I was talking about satanic
fantasy channel that was you know still
very much in effect in 1993 particularly
in this part of Arkansas which like I
said this is very very very Bible Belt
you know a relatively small town the
weird thing about the this town in
particular I don't know about nowadays
but in 1993 a lot of poverty um a lot of
crime this is actually one of the
highest crime cities in Arkansas at
least it was at the time but despite
that as we'll see the police in West
Memphis Arkansas
um not prepared I guess just to put it
charitably to deal with a crime of this
magnitude so may 5th 1993 there are
three eight-year-old boys who are all
friends Stevie branch Michael Moore and
Christopher Byers now they played
together pretty much every day after
school they would go and ride their
little bikes or their little skateboards
or whatever like eight-year-old boys do
so may 5th they're seen playing together
at around 6:30 p.m. and shortly after
that um they disappeared now so that you
know that one of the boys stepfathers
buyers stepfather John Mark Byers he
decides you know since he can't find the
kid and he's like well you know they
kind of look around for him it's like
ask around where they are and nobody
knows so they um you know so they report
the children missing to the police once
they determined that they have no idea
where they have gone now they kind of go
around and they search anything and they
don't find anything that night now the
next morning they start um you know kind
of a more thorough search with the
police involved they kind of go around
there canvassing the whole area they
start looking around this place called
Robin Hood Hills which was a place where
it was kind of like I guess it was sort
of like this wooded area behind there
was like this big I guess it was kind of
like a truck stop in a way that was like
a cafe there and like truckers would
park there to get their trucks cleaned
and all this other kind of stuff and I
guess there was like um you know like a
wooded area or like some kind of ravine
or something and a lot of kids would go
there to play so they started looking
around there and did like kind of a
shoulder-to-shoulder type of thing but
they didn't find anything again
now 1:45 p.m. on the afternoon of May
6th this guy named Steve Jones who we'll
talk about a little bit more later he
was a parole officer and he was
searching around in this you know this
little creek bed that was in Robin Hood
Hills and he sees a little boys black
tennis shoe floating in the creek
so he wades into the creek and start and
this is [ __ ] horrifying I could just
imagine like if this [ __ ] happened so
he wades into the creek and he starts
and it's real muddy
you know it's the [ __ ] Arkansas and
it's like you know almost summertime so
he's you know and it's [ __ ] mosquitos
and [ __ ] like that so he's like wading
around in the [ __ ] and then his leg
catches on something and he like kind of
trips and falls backwards and a boy's
naked body like floats to the surface of
the creek so then they start like you
know feeling around down there and to
the two other bodies come up from the
bottom of the creek now all three boys
had been essentially hogtied I guess I
guess hogtied is like when you do the
opposite risk to the opposite ankle but
this was like the same risk to the same
angle like behind in the back they had
been tied with their own shoelaces they
were all found naked they found some of
their clothes nearby weirdly they found
two of the boys jeans they had been like
taken off they were like inside out but
like the zippers and the buttons were
still done up two of the boys underwear
I don't think they ever found I don't
know if they found like an either shirt
or anything like that but they did find
the pants and they thought it was weird
that it looked like the pants had been
taken off you know they don't know no
they took them off like maybe they took
off their clothes to go swim in the
creek I don't know why they would but um
you know or whatever happened but that
you know they had been taken off like
without being unbuttoned with it which
they thought was not a killer dude yeah
so fetishizing over [ __ ] little boy's
clothes or something I think here's the
okay so the strange thing about this so
you know they find um you know they find
these three bodies and if you watch I
can't remember improves west of Memphis
or Paradise Lost like I said they're
both you can rent them on YouTube is
only $2.99 or three night under
something like that and one of the
documentaries you know if you want to
watch it be prepared because they do
actually show police footage of them
pulling the bodies out of the creek and
like the bodies laying there on the bank
and everything like that and it's pretty
gross you know they the boys weren't
not I'm not even real sure like what the
cause of death was like two of them they
think it was drowning or that they were
beaten now one of the boys Christopher
Byers initially looked like he had been
sexually mutilated in that his I believe
his scrotum and penis were gone or
mutilated however even though it kind of
got around later on because of rumors
and because of various other things that
the boys had been raped that was
actually not the case
so maybe fish did it well well yeah
we'll get into that actually that's
actually very insightful for you too
okay now time of death all the same time
yes yes so yeah this is a very very
strange case it almost doesn't sound
like a serial killer
um too many too many mmm well I don't
think it was like I said I'll get into
that okay so the pathologist Frank
Peretti he did the autopsies and he he
determined that Christopher Byers had
died from quote-unquote multiple
injuries and that Michael Moore and
Stevie branch had died of multiple
injuries with drowning so like I said
most things I saw said they were like
beaten I think one of them had like a
kind of a wound on the side of his head
if you see the documentary which
actually shows the bodies and you can
get like it's pretty I mean they're not
like mutilated or anything they were in
the water for like a day but you know
there its rigor mortis and these so
there's these like naked little boys and
they're just like laying in the bank and
they're all you know tied back like that
and they're like stiff you know they
don't look like they're that beat-up but
there are like some little marks on them
that and this was another point of
contention that initially the autopsy
report said were knife wounds or from a
knife that had been scraped down their
skin although like I said I don't later
later examination like called that into
question
so I so I'm thinking that the boys were
taught were tied up and beaten and then
thrown into the water and then they
drowned that's what it appears to me
they were not stabbed they were not you
know anything like that there were no
stab wounds how old were they again 8
another interesting thing about the
crime scene was that they never could
determine whether the boys were murdered
there or murdered elsewhere and then
dumped there because really I don't
think they found they either found no
blood or a very very tiny amount of
blood like at the scene and you know
they didn't really find that much other
evidence either I think they found like
some very very trace DNA like on a part
of the clothing which you know may not
have had anything to do with the crime
and it's like you know no footprints no
nothing like that
so they were kind of stymied from the
beginning and like I said this is West
Memphis Arkansas the police were not
really equipped to deal with a crime of
this magnitude a triple homicide of
three children another thing too is that
and this you know had to do with like
you know the whole politics of the place
the Arkansas State Police offered to
step in and help them and like give them
some you know some of their resources
and stuff and the West Memphis Police
turned them down probably because the
Arkansas State Police were in at that
time I believe investigating the West
Memphis Police for various I believe it
was some kind of drug trafficking or
some kind of [ __ ] so they didn't want
any help from the state even though I'm
sure it would have been very helpful
because as you'll see I think they
botched this [ __ ]
big-time you know so they let people
like kind of stomp all over the crime
scene like I said they didn't get a
great deal of evidence and you know that
kind of and also I think that there were
you know people involved who kind of had
their eye on a suspect before they'd
even done anything or gathered in the
evidence and then it seems like they
kind of built a narrative around that
person you know and just threw away
anything that wasn't of that narrative
if you know what I mean now they did
look into a couple other suspects before
the more famous Westman Memphis Three
you know suspects who would later end up
being convicted now the first two of
these was two teenage boys named Chris
Morgan and Brian Holland now they were
thinking about these two because these
two kids came up on the radar because
four days after the bodies were found
they abruptly took off for California so
they actually I guess the Arkansas
police you know
contacted the police in Oceanside
California where they had gone it was
like hey can you like snag them for a
second cuz you know maybe they'd had
something to do with this murder
so they brought them in they both took
polygraph tests which indicated that
they may not have been being completely
truthful when asked about the murder
like if they had anything to do with the
murder now one of the guys Chris Morgan
then later said that he was way into
like drugs and he was an alcoholic
because a lot of these people were like
paint hoppers and so I mean this is
Arkansas so girl I get him into meth and
like I mean teenagers and stuff there's
nothing else to do I'm just saying that
it's like these teenagers in like this
tiny little town in Arkansas so you know
and even some of the people involved in
this case like admitted that they were
like huffing gas and like all that kind
of stuff because it was [ __ ] boring
around there right so this so Chris
Morgan evidently said that it's like you
know I could have killed those boys I
have blackouts I don't really remember
now
even though that seems you know I'm not
saying the dude was guilty or anything
but it's easy but it seems a little
damning but it seems that the police
didn't really follow up on that so I
guess the kids were just allowed to stay
in California I don't know what the hell
ever happened to them like I said I I
suspect that maybe someone else was
involved so I don't know if it anything
to do with them now
another weird thing that happened on the
same day that may or may not be relevant
and they call this guy who is an unknown
suspect they call him mr. Bojangles
because well because this was a guy and
they didn't find out about this until
later on
this was a guy that on the evening of
the murders which was May 5th 1993 about
quarter to 9:00 in the evening the
employees of the Bojangles restaurant
they reported that this that this black
guy came in and he was like covered with
blood or he you know he looked like
wounded I don't know if it was his blood
or someone else's blood but he came in
there and he seemed like really
disoriented and he went into the ladies
room and then he was in there for a
while so the employees called the cops
the cops came by the time the cops got
there the guy was gone now they did so
here's what I mean about the cops so the
cops apparently took some blood
scrapings cuz I mean the employees had
to clean up all the blood because it
took the cops so long to get there
because you know it's a restaurant and
you can't like leave blood all over the
[ __ ] walls of the bathroom so they
kind of cleaned it up you know a little
bit so the cops like took some blood
scrapings from the wall of the bathroom
like from the blood that was remaining
however then later on one of the
geniuses at the police department lost
the blood samples so they never even got
to check them I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to these blood samples I don't
know if he lost him on purpose or what
and like I said I don't know if this was
just like a coincidence maybe this guy
was just like crazy maybe he had cut
himself maybe he didn't know where he
was and he just wandered into this
restaurant and it didn't have anything
to do with the crime but that is
something that a lot of people you know
point out it's like hey maybe that had
something to do with it now I'm not
buying it because that's what I mean a
lot of weird [ __ ] happens my areas
that's what I know you can you can
[ __ ] you can you could link anything
with anything right I just found that
this guy may not have had anything to do
with I think it was just like a
coincidence that he was just like having
problems anyone yeah you got to have a
physical [ __ ] forensic link yeah it's
not just because you know well you know
this one dude was walking around yeah it
doesn't work that way yeah exactly and
so even though it would have been nice
if that one guy at the police department
hadn't lost the blood sample so they
could have like checked it Elysa those
are their priorities were over there
they really didn't give a [ __ ] yeah so I
don't think they were [ __ ] real
Arkansas I don't think these are real
competent [ __ ] cops uh I would agree
with that assessment yeah now okay so it
seems to me that right from the
beginning of the investigation they
pretty much okay because one of the boys
genitals had been
deleted or so they made it appear and
because it appeared as though they had
like knife wounds and stuff or it looked
like and they were hogtied like the way
they were tied and they were naked and
all this other kind of stuff so some of
the people in the police department and
some of these other people in town were
immediately like Satan it's a satanic
cult it looked ritualistic okay that's
it that's a huge job uh yeah they
usually yeah it is a very big leap yeah
now one of the things so Steve Jones who
I mentioned before who is the guy that
found the bodies and you know that's not
you know I'm not [ __ ] on the dude
too much cuz that's got to be super
traumatic like walking through the mud
like [ __ ] you know tripping over
essentially an eight-year-old boys naked
body I mean that's got to be pretty
messed up however Steve Jones who was a
parole officer and his buddy Jerry
driver who these guys weren't cops but
they were like I think Jerry driver what
the [ __ ] was he he was like not a
private investigator but he was some
other kind of like lesser type of thing
these two guys were like convinced that
there was satanic cult activity big time
in West Memphis Arkansas so much so that
even before the murders happened these
two jokers would drive around on the
nights of full moons hoping to catch
some [ __ ] Sabbath's going on yeah you
know what I mean but they're watching to
be seventies moves right so it's like no
seriously these guys are like the type
of dudes that like took that [ __ ] super
serious you know they had seen like all
those like shitty satanic panic like cop
training videos and all that kind of
stuff it's like look at the pentagram
drawn in the finger and that means a
satanic crime and all yeah matter of
fact our first show our second show we
actually did some excerpts from the cop
radio I can't remember the name of that
guy was like come on Eve is so [ __ ]
funny what they were teaching cops you
see you understand some police
organizations and sometimes even
military organizations will hire [ __ ]
outside contractors to come in and teach
him stuff all right
some [ __ ] police some police group
somewhere fell for this one guy he I
don't remember the dude's name but
he had a bunch of videos made a bunch of
training pack just made and he would go
around all these local [ __ ] County
police outfits and sell them this
[ __ ] package of training it was
[ __ ] ridiculous identified a kind of
identified cult activity [ __ ] VHS
tapes made a killing selling those oh
yeah then you can get up and [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] speech and probably give
a couple classes on how to identify [ __ ]
it was all bunk yeah I could cut I could
maybe understand how you might fall for
that [ __ ] back in the 80s if you were of
a certain age you know too old to know
better but but the [ __ ] they were
talking about a [ __ ] a teenager of
the time would just laugh at that yeah
of course yeah and it's just it's sad to
me that it took so long for people to
realize like how [ __ ] that was yeah
and I'm not saying and I think I
probably mentioned this on the satanic
panic show I'm not saying that like
isolated cult type murders do occur in a
sense that you know somebody wants to
make it look like ritualistic or
somebody does that it does happen like
in isolation the Manson family was a
cult murder right and I think you know
that type of thing Richard Ramirez like
more that kind of stuff like it kind of
contributed even though I don't think
Richard Ramirez was really a Satanist he
was really doing he was just doing it to
like be shocking look at me he was a
self-styled
which I think most of the crimes that
have those kind of trappings that's what
people are doing they're trying to be
scarier they're trying to be and by you
and by like these kind of like older
people are like these kind of maybe not
as well educated people like kind of
falling for it
you're just playing into their game I
mean that's what they want they lot of
it I'm afraid
had to do with the religion of the time
yeah okay your your local police
department usually was just they were
just regular church-going just regular
people they believed what they heard
from the pulpit well you had some guys
who were had a religious background that
said well I'm gonna [ __ ] make money
off this yeah and
come up with a package of training to
sell to the police and the zeitgeist of
the time it kind of [ __ ] worked was
it true
no it wasn't true the FBI even told them
that the I would go and go this is
[ __ ] I think you're in the early 90s
the FBI came and was like look we have
found no evidence like I said they do
happen in isolation maybe yeah but it's
like this whole thing that you have
about that there's like the this network
of like satanic cults like sacrificing
babies and like it it's like that just
doesn't happen it just I it's not
possible to keep hidden for that amount
of time know something that extent you
if you just there's just no way right
you know what I mean and then you got
[ __ ] like and it took something like
like I said the McMartin preschool trial
case I'm like all that kind of stuff
where all those people are like
wrongfully accused to finally get people
to be like Oh duh this is all funny
stupidest [ __ ] now could there be a
group of guys real rich guys that own
islands and [ __ ] are they able to
come down here to Florida and get a
bunch of young girls to go down and go
to this island and pimp themselves out
hell yeah yeah it's like as far as very
different damn [ __ ] satanic that's
what I mean a nationwide network is very
different than like kind of a small
group of rich dudes cuz you all know I
can't say it but we all know that child
Island demand did not commit take his
own life
child Island man did not shake his
Island and we call him child Island man
did not take his own life we know that
but yes so like I said that's and we
kind of get into this a little bit right
there are groups about conspiracies yes
it's like I'm not saying that there's
not conspiracies it's just that the
larger they are the less likely they are
wrong exists because someone would find
out about it child Island man was all
about real rich powerful guys and this
going to this damn Island and doing
these [ __ ] hot young things and join
in some kind of club where they all had
dirt on one another that's what I
believe it was yeah and like I said it's
a relatively small group of people right
that had had a lot of power
well that and that had incentive to keep
it quiet yes they had there was like a
lot of blackmail yeah and then once you
once you joined that Club you were in
the Brotherhood and then
were all working together that's what I
believe was going on but like I said
nationwide network of satanic cults
having been yes to sacrifice at the
middle class and lower class level I'm
no that would only be a span dudes they
had a lot of money and like I said the
more the the square old people were
afraid of the [ __ ] the more teenagers
would do it it's like I used to do the
same thing you know what it might be
crew with your shout at the devil album
right all that [ __ ] it's fun to like
piss people like that off cuz it's so
easy when your mom's telling you that
that's the devil's music then you go
damn alright well I must being with the
devil so like I said it's like so these
two guys like [ __ ] Jerry driver and
Steve Jones driving around West Memphis
Arkansas of all [ __ ] places and it's
like every time they see like a random
like you know upside down cross or
pentagram spray-painted under an
overpass somewhere they think that
there's some kind of like satanic cult
I'm like no that's just bored ass kids
yeah doing that like to shock people
like you because they know it works and
just because every now and then one of
those groups becomes the Manson Family
it doesn't mean they're all like that
right legs and family was kind of like
that but the Manson Family involved
having access to an old [ __ ] movie
studio one two having access to a whole
bunch of LSD and a whole bunch of
homeless girls they had run away to
[ __ ] California that's how the Manson
I mean that was an aberration it was
kinda it was that's why people don't
think about it right you know that's why
people still talking it's an extreme
case of teenagers yeah acting up so I
think that you know so you have to
understand like the whole environment of
the time that contributed to this
because allegedly reportedly even while
they when they brought the little boys
bodies and they were on the bank of the
creek and the cops were coming and stuff
you took like they didn't call the
coroner for one for two hours the
coroner didn't show up until two hours
after the bodies were found for whatever
reason and by that time like maggots had
already started yes they'd already
started decompose and stuff like that so
and also I think that the first guy that
did you know the medical examiner didn't
do a
bang-up job so a lot of the stuff that
he said was later determined by other
independent you know researchers experts
stuff like that that looked into the
case was later determined to be
erroneous so a lot of the stuff that
they used to prosecute the West Memphis
from 3 was later found out to be
[ __ ] which is why they eventually um
got set free so allegedly reportedly
steve jones the guy that found the
bodies he supposedly said when they were
at the creek standing over the bodies
it looks like damien echols has finally
killed somebody now Damien Echols was a
teenager who lived in the town and he
was um you know he was like the your
troubled teen you know I mean he were
black he liked Metallica like he had
long black hair he would go around
saying that he was Wiccan or satanic or
whatever like a lot of teenagers at that
time did like I said just to shock
people you know he wrote Goffe poetry
like all that kind of see if he was
different and he stood out and all the
cops is a fairly small towns all the
cops knew him and they suspected that he
was into a cult activity because he had
some you know books by Anton LaVey or
whatever like he was into that kind of
[ __ ] yeah what was funny this time you
know during this period of course this
is the pre-internet era information
didn't flow very quickly back then it
was real easy for somebody cuz me and
Jenny who came from this background yeah
I remember this it was real easy during
that era to not want to be associated
with the mainstream yeah so you wanted
to [ __ ] have your own thing and the
only other option were things kind of
like you know goth culture and or heavy
metal and black clothing and [ __ ]
weird writers from the past and Anton
LaVey
that was our version of the Internet it
was trying to break out of the damn
mainstream thinking yeah but it wasn't
like the kind of thing where because
you're now reading these books you were
gonna go out commit murders [ __ ]
varied no [ __ ] no it was it was like
style yeah more than anything else and
the sad thing about it and particularly
in the case of Damien Echols who was
seen as like the ringleader of this even
though yes he was a very troubled kid he
had grown up in extreme poverty and I'm
not talking about you know we didn't
have a big-screen TV poverty I'm talking
about no electricity like [ __ ] dirt
floor Shack poppers yes so of course
that was his version of the mainstream
would you want to be in that mainstream
right that's what I mean no and he had
gotten in trouble for a fairly minor
[ __ ] like in the past burglary that type
is you know breaking and entering that
type of stuff um so you know I'm not
saying that he was an angel he was a
messed up kid he really was and um you
know the fact that he was but I have to
say that he kind of had a lot of problem
that a lot of kids who are different
kind of run into when you grow up in
environments like this not just the
extreme poverty that he grew up in but
also this kind of like real
closed-minded kind of town where
everyone just like sees you as like a
weirdo or a freak and so I think that's
why like you know it as we'll see later
on like why a lot of kind of you know
celebrities and why a lot of people why
this case resonated with a lot of people
because they could relate to growing up
in these small towns and having everyone
hate you just because you looked a
little bit different and he didn't look
all that weird back then I just think
what's funny is like working class or
lower class goth type kids were [ __ ]
rebelling against their version of the
mainstream which is just [ __ ] poor
people really okay
poor working-class people they didn't
want it didn't want to be that yeah in
my case I [ __ ] came up around some of
the richest people in the [ __ ] world
growing up in Brazil the school of I
wanted this someone father when [ __ ] I
was rebelling against rich kids yeah I
didn't want to be like them you know I
thought I thought they were pampered and
ridiculous you know so it can its kids
in extreme environments yeah I was
coming from an extreme preppy [ __ ]
school well I didn't want anything to do
I had it both ways because I grew up you
know really poor but then like later
when I went to high school and stuff
like that it was kind of with like up
more upper-middle class kids
I didn't really like either one of those
cultures so I was kind of like trying to
get away from both of them yeah I didn't
want to [ __ ] be like these [ __ ]
spoiled yuppie kids yeah I mean they
wanted to go to these Ivy League schools
[ __ ] no I wanted to go at that time I
wanted to go to the Marine Corps and be
[ __ ] like marine infantry yeah of it
or army or some [ __ ] like this you know
I just didn't like it you know so my
version of not going along with that
[ __ ] system was joining the army and
[ __ ] you no time in listening to
[ __ ] guys music is [ __ ] yeah it's
just it's it's it's it's if you're in an
extreme environment either one of those
extremes yeah so I can so I can see
where this kid is coming from even
though like I said you know he had
committed crimes he what he did have
some psychiatric problems and stuff like
that but honestly after he got out like
I've seen a bunch of interviews with him
that came out like just in the last
couple years and stuff like that he is
clearly very intelligent very articulate
you know and I so I feel like you know I
can relate to feeling like trapped in
the environment that he was in um you
know wanting something more out of life
and like wanting spendin like rebelling
and kind of the only way he knew how
yeah so extreme poverty and extreme
riches are [ __ ] two extremes they're
both [ __ ] up yeah they're both [ __ ]
up so you wouldn't think so
yeah but no man if I could rich people
are [ __ ] [ __ ] well yeah they're
real [ __ ] I think most people know
that it would have had to like deal with
them for any stretch of though you don't
really get that rich if you're not an
[ __ ] yeah yeah and they're thinking
and that's an older generation they're
they've pretty much gone now they're
dead now yeah but back in those days
[ __ ] know if you had [ __ ] rich
yuppie parents [ __ ] they were [ __ ]
yeah
but yeah so so they bring in Damien
Echols like I said it really does seem
like allegedly that you know Steve Jones
who like I said he's not a cop he's like
a juvenile probation officer or some
[ __ ] like that him and his little buddy
Jerry driver they had just decided that
because this kid were black and liked
Metallica and was in
weird [ __ ] that he must be the one the
go-to because this was clearly a
ritualistic satanic murder yada yada so
this is clearly like who it was right so
they bring him in for questioning and
you know like I said and you know he
admits this nowadays to now that he's
older he's like look you know I was a
kid at the time he was only like 16 or
17 or whatever he's like I was probably
my own worst enemy because you know not
only was I you know looked all Goffe and
everything but he also had the attitude
you know what I mean where it's like you
know what the [ __ ] can you guys do like
you don't know anything and you know
thinking he was smarter than them and
stuff so he probably didn't come across
all that well so they did question him
about the murder he denied having
anything to to do with the murder
however um so the polygraph that they
gave him said that he was being
deceptive however from what I have heard
from all of these documentaries that I
watching all the [ __ ] that I was you
know reading about this apparently there
was not I'm not really sure like how you
like report the polygraph like to the
cops or whatever like because they bring
the polygraph guy in he gives him the
polygraph one the guy that gave the
polygraph didn't tell the cops what
questions he asked like that was an on
record um also basically all he did was
just play oh he failed like that's all
he said you know I mean he didn't say
Bleich what the questions were like what
the answers were nothing
so basically I mean that's what I heard
pricey I'm saying I'm thinking like I
said I'm 98% sure that this guy and the
other two guys that were convicted did
not do this [ __ ] I mean it's possible I
just think it's highly highly unlikely
but I do think that because he looked
like he would be in a satanic cult that
they kind of focused on him and then
built the case around him rather than
letting the evidence leading them yeah I
know [ __ ] some people are gonna jump
on us but me and Jenny were there some
of you guys I [ __ ] attest to it I can
see I totally saw but happy that you
were God's back in those days it was
messed up you hear I'm so easy now to
die before talk about how [ __ ] the
cops are pick on him it was yeah of
course you could get a shot at [ __ ] like
that it was bad on [ __ ] gods too
I mean I thought you were doing
something like sacrificing babies and
and they're like just they're making it
up in their head they were just yet they
built a whole entire thing
around I mean like I said Steve Jones
reportedly while they were like but you
know they just got the bodies out of the
[ __ ] Creek and the first thing he
said was oh looks like Damien killed
somebody so he had already decided that
that's who did it but were they even
like looked into this here's the thing
you know I mean they're saying that just
based on their prejudices of the time
hindsight and [ __ ] experience at
doing these cases me and jenni done a
lot of these cases we know this kind of
[ __ ] real well chances are it was a
[ __ ] they never would have
suspected a guy all I did this was a
middle-aged man who is married um
probably who I suspect well if the cops
had actually done their due diligence I
think I'm not gonna say that I know who
it is because I might get sued but I'm
not the only person that's saying that
they're pretty sure that they know maybe
is somebody they didn't suspect um
yeah we'll get it we'll get it you think
they had it's just they had a suspect
yeah no I know I it's I'll get into it
okay it's usually the same race usually
it's [ __ ] well I guess you get it's
not always a married man but it's
usually somebody that they don't they
don't suspect that's how that's why I'm
going to say before we get into it that
they should have suspected this person
okay like I think they kind of did maybe
like for a second but I don't think they
suspected him till much later like when
more evidence came out okay um but he
was a person that they should have
suspected but he's just a regular
challenged person when he mm-hmm
that's I thought he wasn't one of these
weird goth kids or [ __ ] there how
often do you see is this somebody that
looks like a goth or a punk or yeah a
metalhead or somebody how often do you
see that I'm not doing that as a serial
killer like youth they catch the serum
no it's almost always like a
normal-looking normal he's kind of like
a dork oh all the time
99% of the time it's just a
normal-looking person because if they
looked like like and I've said this
before I was just like look you can't
walk into a bank with an 8-foot green
mohawk and rob the [ __ ]
and expect to not get caught yeah
everyone's gonna remember you well if
you're gonna go and rob a bank and
you've got a look it's like everyone
else if you're gonna go rob a bank what
makes you think you're gonna go into
robbing that Bank with the 8 foot tall
green bow heart you must be a dumb
[ __ ]
oh yeah well yeah and I'm just saying
they catch you immediately but like I
don't put a damn hat off a really big
head like one of those big ten yeah look
all right there's a big foam cowboy hat
yeah because a lot of the subculture
[ __ ] fashion was about [ __ ] kind of
like standing out that's what I mean
about know if you're gonna commit crimes
you don't want to stand out I want to
blend in I mean if you're a serial
killers no it's like look at all the
[ __ ] zeros like Ted Bundy look at all
this bleep they don't look like anyone
that you would remember necessarily it's
like you don't want to stand out cuz you
don't want to get caught yeah duh it's
like you don't want to walk around with
[ __ ] fishnets and corsets and [ __ ] on
blending in is [ __ ] the type of
camouflage yeah it's urban camouflage it
is so you just want to kind of look like
everyone else yeah
so you know like I said this whole thing
is [ __ ] up ok so they initially they
bring him in like I said there was a
whole [ __ ] with the polygraph and
then um you know initially I think they
said that oh we he's not a suspect we
just brought him in because we think he
has information about the case now it
should be noted that him and the other
two guys that eventually got convicted
they didn't know those kids you know I
mean they didn't they didn't know who
they were
um not really I mean they might have
known them like around cuz it was a
small town or whatever but they didn't
know them so then later June 3rd like a
few days after the bodies were found
they bring in another guy who was like
an acquaintance of Damien Echols I don't
think he knew him all that well but he
was kind of like you know an
acquaintance type of thing now this was
a guy named Jessie Misskelley now this
kid only had I mean he had an IQ I've
seen between 72 and 85 dumbest [ __ ] this
so I mean he was mentally challenged
alright now I've seen like interviews
with him and stuff he doesn't he's not
like um you know he can still function
like he can still have a job and stuff
but
he seems to have like the mentality of
maybe like a five to eight year old
child you know what I mean so the
problem was even though he was a minor
they bring him in for questioning and
because he was like an associate of
damien echols
they bring him in without his parents
even though he is mentally challenged i
guess his dad said okay you can take him
in for questioning but they didn't know
that he was they he was gonna be like
interrogated about the murder and stuff
um usually if it's a kid or if it's you
know someone who it has diminished
mental capacity yeah they're supposed to
have someone there with them so they
questioned him for 12 hours of which
only about an hour and a half of that
recording survives yeah they grilled the
[ __ ] out of that kid if you get your
hands on a dumb person you can you [ __ ]
with him for a long time you can get him
to confess well they did do sure they
did you're gonna be fastest [ __ ] they
didn't do yeah yeah so basically and
okay so the recordings of that survive
of this 12 hour interrogation are very I
mean to me and I'm not a perfect you
know I'm not a professional I'm not a
cop I'm not anything like that but to me
it very clearly sounds like they are
extremely leading questions okay
basically how you do you have to keep
you posed to ask him where they took the
kid what they do how they did you know
how did you tie them up did you tie them
up you have to ask them questions that
isn't what happened and because if they
answer if the answers are all wrong then
you know that the person didn't do it
because they're yeah I'm making it up I
got the distinct impression and like I
said a lot of this interrogation is gone
you coincidentally that's because it
[ __ ] they [ __ ] [ __ ] that kid over
um you know but even the part that
survives I mean I think it's pretty
damning on the cops because okay so they
would ask something like this and
forgive me if I can't like remember like
word-for-word but he said this is this
is one thing that stood out to me so the
kids were killed like in the evening you
know what I mean because they were last
seen around 6:30 7:00 p.m.
and then they never came home and then
they weren't really found until the next
day and they'd been in the water for a
while so it must have been like sometime
after 7 p.m. that they were killed so
they start talking to Jessie Misskelley
and he initially they're like okay well
what time was it when you took the kids
or when you saw the kids or whatever he
initially said noon he said noon and
then the cops said oh well you mean it
was after school
yeah after school and then like as they
kept toast so it was evening to her it
was nighttime or some like yeah
nighttime so you could tell that the kid
was just trying to tell them what they
wanted to hear so he could go home right
yeah essentially yeah I do like yeah
well he it really gave the impression of
you know what do you want me to tell you
so I can leave well they probably told
him that if you tell us this you can go
home yeah I think that's probably what
they told him and I think that was
probably on the part of the recording
that they convenient or that they didn't
record I'm just gonna tell him whatever
they wanted to hear well yeah he was
guilty or not because what wasn't guilty
because you guilty he would have told
him what happened because he initial I
mean he very clearly said that it was
noon he said that it was noon because he
hadn't gone to school that day he said
and like I said the crime happened in
the evening so they got him to go later
and later in the day until finally he
was like yeah the night know what that
means he didn't do it he also said that
the kids were tied up with rope which
they weren't it was shoelaces he also
said that he saw Damien Echols raping
the boys the boys were not raped so a
lot of the [ __ ] that he came up with you
could tell that he was just trying to
feeling around to tell them what they
wanted to hear because he thought I mean
like I said he was not he was not a
smart boy of 70 IQs [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ]
man [ __ ] dumb you know anyway I mean
he seemed like a lovely person he seems
like a really nice person site that's
mentally incompetent yes he didn't
really seem to understand what you know
what was going on or you know what his
rights were what they were trying he was
just trying to like tell them the story
that they wanted so he could leave no he
should have been quick you know
questioning somebody of the
with an IQ that low without out without
the presence of a [ __ ] a defense
attorney that's [ __ ] [ __ ] there was
nobody as parents but there are nothing
right and it's like that's that is
highly highly I don't know if it's
illegal but it's really really enough it
should be illegal yeah I don't know if
it's ill I don't know about Arkansas but
you know what I mean there's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] up laws in Arkansas which
I get into a little bit too but so so
Jessie Misskelley basically confessed
that they had done this he said that he
hadn't killed any of them themselves but
that one of them had one of the boys had
tried to run away and he had like
corralled the kid back and he so he came
up with this story then like I said
there were a lot of inconsistencies in
it that were not you know not correct
like with the actual details of the
crime now the day after he confessed
because he because he said it was him
and Damien Echols and another guy and
that they had done this Jason Baldwin I
think is the other one's name and so the
next day like after he made that
confession he recanted he said no that's
not what happened he's like you know
they had him in there for 12 hours he
was scared of them
you know they made threats or veiled
threats or he you know he wasn't really
sure what was going on so he took it
back now he also said that they had
informed him of his Miranda rights but
that he didn't understand what they were
talking about um like I said this is you
know someone with a mentality of like a
small child so he really didn't clearly
didn't understand like the gravity of
what was going on so however because he
played into the narrative that they
wanted and they got him to say what they
wanted him to say which like I said if
you listen the recordings it very much
does sound like they're trying to lead
him into the [ __ ] narrative that they
want especially with the [ __ ] with the
time of day and all that kind of stuff
but a so he confessed and even though he
recanted the next day the cops still
arrested Damien Echols and Jason Baldwin
who was the other guy that was involved
who's Echols and Baldwin were actually
really close friends now so so they say
they all get arrested now the shitty
thing about this was that it seemed like
if you watch the first part of the HBO
documentary paradise loss because they
made like three parts I think like
several years apart so the first one
that they made came out in 1996 which
was just three years after the crimes
and it seemed like as soon as these
three boys got arrested mostly the whole
town had decided well they got him
that's who did it
I mean Jessie Misskelley confessed he
said that they did it so that was kind
of the end of it and you could see and
I'm not gonna [ __ ] on you know the
parents of the boys I understand it's
like look their eight-year-old son just
got murdered that's [ __ ] up you know
they want somebody to blame and but it
just seems like they just went off on
this [ __ ] you know they just wanted
to kill these teenage boys before they
even went to trial before idea evidence
came out or anything like that everyone
just it was like a total witch hunt they
just like jumped on the [ __ ] and like I
said I understand that they were
grieving and that this was a horrible
thing to happen to them but it's like I
don't really think that was super
helpful I mean particularly the guy the
stepdad of Christopher Byers who was
briefly a suspect but that guy did
really not come off very well in the
first documentary and he actually
complained about it later on because I
mean he was seen in the documentary
setting up what were they like pumpkins
or cans or something like that and
saying that each of that these were like
the three boys the three you know
teenagers that got arrested and he's
like I'm gonna blow him in half boom
boom and he was like shooting them and
all this other kind of stuff and I'm
like dude that is they haven't even got
a trial yet that is really not helping
it's like it's making you look like a
lunatic and he did come out later I mean
he had a brain tumor he was an alcoholic
he was on all kind of like medications
and stuff and he was like they made me
look really bad and you know to his
credit even though he looks like a you
know a crazy person in the first
documentary he did come out later and
say even though he initially thought
that the three boys were guilty he did
come out later and say that he didn't
think that they had done it and so he
did do a 180 and two
come out and apologize and all the other
kind of stuff so to his credit even
though he looks like a nut in the first
one so eight months after um Jesse's
initial confession um he actually so
Jessie Misskelley he's he says that he
wants to make another statement to the
police
now his lawyer tells him not to but then
Jesse comes up with this other story
where he again says that they did it but
now he adds like new details which I'm
not entirely sure why they did this and
this this is very weird to me because it
did seem like the confessed too much
emphasis was put on the confession
because even the judge in this case
barnett i think his name was he actually
said on camera i don't know
i don't think that anyone would falsely
confess to a crime I'm like are you high
that happens all the time why do you
think that they keep details back from
the press and all this other kind of
stuff just for exactly that reason I'm
like a masochist this month how long
have you been a judge masochistic
[ __ ] lunatics that'll show up because
I killed the person right yeah yeah yeah
they just like one attention or
something like that what yeah and like I
said you know I killed job at a Ramsey
yeah and then they can't answer any of
the [ __ ] question about the case and
I think that I mean I don't think that
that's why Jessie Misskelley did it um I
think that in his case I'm not really
sure he understood like I said the
gravity of the situation and I think
that he was just desperately trying to
tell them the narratives that they
wanted to hear because I think that he
thought that if he told them what they
wanted to hear then maybe he wouldn't
get in trouble you know what I mean so
it really did seem to him because a lot
of people have pointed this oh this does
mean they're guilty because even eight
months later when he wasn't under direct
police interrogation he went in again
and you know reiterated even though he
had recanted like the first confession
he went in later and he's like yeah here
it is we did this that and the other
thing but like I said he added details
that hadn't been you know that he hadn't
confessed the first time it's like it's
a lot of the details were wrong and all
this other stuff so I really do think
that he was just trying to make
this he was trying to do the correct
narrative so that he wouldn't be in
trouble anymore
I really feel like that's kind of what
what his mindset was um you know I'm not
entirely sure but that is kind of how it
plays out to me so yeah so also there
was this woman named cuz holy [ __ ]
there's there's so much horrible [ __ ]
that happened in this [ __ ] so there's
this other woman named Vicky Hutchins
Hutchison now she had just moved to West
Memphis shortly before the murders
now she said that um like the day after
the murders took place she had been
under who she got arrested and was
undergoing a polygraph for an unrelated
charge she had like they thought she had
stolen some money from her job or
something like that now while she was in
there like being questioned for that
crime her son Aaron was there and he and
Aaron who I think was only seven or
eight years old he happened to say to
the guy who was administering the
polygraph he's like oh the boys got
killed at the quote-unquote Playhouse
okay now this was before the bodies were
found like shortly before the bodies
were found now so when they found the
bodies sort of near where this little
kid had said that they were killed so
they thought well maybe there was a you
know this playhouse or whatever you know
maybe that had something to do with it
so they asked this little kid well it
was like what else do you know about
this stuff and he said that he saw the
murders committed or had you know had
seen some of it or something and they
were Satanists of course and that they
had spoke in Spanish um also it's only
foreign language you know I guess he
also said like a lot of the details that
he gave her just like contradictory also
they showed him you know photos of
Damien Echols and you know the other end
Jason Baldwin and Jessie Misskelley he
did not recognize them also the place
where he said that there was a play
house there wasn't one there so even
though
even though there was this whole thing
going on like you know that it fueled
into the whole satanic right thing even
though that kid was clearly just pulling
[ __ ] out of his ass and this is why you
don't ask children to be like your main
you don't hang your entire case on the
[ __ ] testimony of a child we talked
about this in some of the satanic panic
cases with like people that said will
they flush the kids down the toilet and
then they went into this like [ __ ]
underground tunnel and all the Chuck
Norris was there HNL Santana this
sickness showed up in a big balloon
right it's crazy
yeah so but because these police for
some reason because this little kid even
though all this [ __ ] that he said was
[ __ ] I still like the only stuff
that he said that had the police pricked
up their ears when he said satanic cult
even though nothing else that he said
was relevant
they told Vicki Hutchins Hutchison his
mom they said okay well we're gonna put
hidden microphones in your house and
then we want you because she knew Jessie
Misskelley but not the other two
so she's like well we want you to have
Damien Echols over at your house because
they wanted him to say something
incriminating and they would like catch
it on the [ __ ] you know microphones
so Jessie Misskelley who like I said at
this point had like made a couple
confessions and gone back on him and
whatever he's like okay we'll all
introduce the two of them so Damien
Echols comes over to Vicki Hutchison's
house and didn't say anything
incriminating even though the cops later
said oh well he probably did say
something incriminating but we couldn't
really hear it it was like garbled or
some [ __ ] like that then you know and
then this woman later went on this
[ __ ] Hutchison woman she later went
on and she testified at the first trial
- is that two weeks after the murder
that her and Damien and Jessie had
attended a Wiccan meeting in another
part of Arkansas and she said that
Damien had bragged about killing the
kids right
except later on many years later after
the boys had already been convicted she
went back on it and said it was all a
[ __ ] lie damn she said that
[Music]
she's like well I didn't want to get in
trouble because like I said she was in
trouble for some mother for embezzlement
and [ __ ] like that so she's like well I
thought that I would get off on that
she's like also I wanted the money for
the reward Oh
so I just hey talk Lahoma so no it's our
Arkansas same difference well
Mississippi's gotta [ __ ] with Arkansas
and Oklahoma so it's like just for her
own associate isn't kids went and like I
said they were in there for 18 years
before they get out Damien Echols was on
death row dan for 18 years and they were
gonna [ __ ] they were gonna get any
like [ __ ] yeah and it's like actually I
mean considering that he seems like
pretty [ __ ] chill 18 years I'd be mad
but he's not mad well he got into like
you know Buddhism and yeah all that kind
of mine yes so he so he seems to I mean
he's still mad about it obviously but
and like I said he still has reason to
be as I'll get into you but yeah he
actually seems a lot more chill than I
would be about the [ __ ] but yeah so um
let's take a break right now and then we
when we come back we'll get into the
trials and just uh what what I think
probably maybe could have happened and
all the [ __ ] that they found out later
like all the evidence that came out
later that the cops just didn't want to
look at and all this other kind of stuff
this is such a depressing case I mean I
guess it sort of had a happy ending
except for you know three boys that got
murdered that's not happy but I mean
yeah for the other people so we're just
gonna take a break right now and we'll
be back in just a few minutes are you
talking about yeah what do you think
yeah I know I love you cue
what are you doing I love you Tina I
want meat what you talking about
what are you talking about what are you
talking about
No oh yeah I know oh she loves feet
she loves feet you love true-crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume 3 is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume 3 is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
hey buddy we're back talking about the
West Memphis Three case so because of
Jessie Misskelley --zz confessions he
was actually put on trial now he was
tried separately from the other two from
Jason Baldwin and Damien Echols just
because according to his confession he
had not directly participated in the
murders but instead had you know he just
said that when one of the boys tried to
run off like he corralled him and
brought him back and then like the other
two boys had done it so he was only
being tried for one count of
first-degree murder because they were
saying that you know if you hadn't gone
and brought that kid back that kid would
still be alive he would have gotten away
or whatever and then the other two were
like second-degree murder now okay
and the fact that they were both being
tried separately was because I guess
they have some kind of rule I think it's
called a Bruton rule I don't know if
they have this everywhere but where his
confession couldn't necessarily be used
against the other two in their trial
however it did seem like Jessie
Misskelley trial was almost entirely
about getting dirt on the other two you
know what I mean so it was more like
they were trying them in absentia
because their trial came like a few
weeks later because I have to say that
other than this poor kids confession
didn't really have a lot of physical
evidence that any of these three were
even there you know what I mean it's
like I think the only physical evidence
that may be sort of could have been used
to like was like I think they found like
a couple of fibers from like a like a
shirt or something like that that one of
their moms owned but the thing about it
was that one that could be secondary
transfer to that fiber that from that
particular garment was very common like
because I mean this is a fairly small
town they all could have shopped at the
same Walmart or whatever and had some of
the same things so that doesn't
necessarily imply that the fabric came
from that house
you know what I'm saying so it's like
they didn't really have anything
physical tying it so it seemed like they
were putting all of their eggs in this
confession basket even though the
confession was clearly not as airtight
as they would have wanted it to be so
the sad thing is that and like I said if
you watch Paradise Lost like the first
part which is kind of like focuses
almost entirely on the trials you know
they show like large chunks of the trial
which was you know which was recorded
and it does seem like they tried to I
mean they brought in an expert from UC
Berkeley who listened to you know what
was left of like the tapes of the
confession like the initial confession
the police interrogation of which like I
said only about an hour and a half out
of 12 hours survived and this expert was
like look this is textbook classic
example of police coercion I mean
they're clearly asking leading questions
like I said even an even a novice like
me could hear that that's exactly what
they were doing they were leading him
into the story that they wanted that
means in a decent State all this [ __ ]
inadmissible in court it should have
been I mean it should have been and so I
mean if it was me if I was sitting on
this jury I really don't think I would
have bought I mean if I had just
listened to that a bit like yeah that
poor kid it's like they just if you have
to convert if you have to [ __ ] coerce
the confession it's not a true
confession anyway right because they're
get to lead them that means this you got
the wrong one yeah you got the right one
he leads you and it all fits the
evidence and like I said a lot of the
[ __ ] that he said was not consistent
with the crime scene like I said there
was the whole thing about oh they were
tied up with rope and they weren't it
was shoelaces and the fact that he said
yeah I saw Damien and I even saw like
this part of the thing where he said in
the confession is like yeah Damien
started screwing him and [ __ ] I think
that's what he said when the boy none of
the boys were raped because initially I
think the cops were operating under the
assumption that the boys had been raped
because there was anal dilation but that
happens death yeah that's that happens
when you die you know you're less not to
be
about it but all your muscular [ __ ] is
goes that's you know and that's why like
you know people a lot of people like
[ __ ] themselves when it dies it's like
that because their muscle a it's just
vacated because so that's what happens
so they didn't find any semen they
didn't find any like bruising or you
know abrasions or anything like that
around the anuses so they you know most
other experts that looked in the case
later on were like yet the boys were not
raped
so obviously that was a massive
inconsistency in this story that you
know the police still took his gospel
because like I said it played into what
they wanted to play into so like I said
even though it seemed like this was the
only [ __ ] [ __ ] that they had Jessie
Misskelley was actually convicted in
February of 1994 of one count of
first-degree murder and two counts of
second-degree murder life plus 40 years
he did appeal the conviction to the
Arkansas Supreme Court but the
conviction was upheld three weeks after
that they tried Damien Echols and Jason
Baldwin together now this was also kind
of a joke because one of the expert
witnesses and if you were listening to
this audio podcast I am making air
quotes yeah was this dude that they
brought in named Dale W Griffiths
now this guy was a supposed and Here I
am with the air quotes again a cult
expert who Jerry driver and Steve Jones
were big fans of like he had written
some books I think he like even wrote
some books subsequently about how to
identify a cult murderers and all that
other stuff okay well it turns out that
this guy who said that he had a PhD I'm
not sure what the PhD was in occult
studies perhaps I don't even know if you
can get a PhD in that you probably can
but it turned out that his PhD was from
Columbia Pacific University not Columbia
University the real one yeah one be a
Pacific University unaccredited mail
order okay the defensive that's a
[ __ ] Hudson that yeah they call a
[ __ ] degree what they call a degree
male yeah it's a diploma belt diploma
Mills yeah that's essentially what it is
and this I mean to me this blows my mind
because I I've seen like portions of the
trial where the defense
terney for the two teenagers says to the
guy what classes did you take to obtain
this PhD and the guy at first tries to
dodge the question this is older looking
dude he first tries to dodge well I've
already said that blah blah blah what
classes did you take says the defense
attorney wall no classes he took no
classes yeah he paid diploma mill and
got a PhD in occult studies and he even
says some stuff like you know the the
OTO the Ordo Templi whatever it is yeah
there we go um he said he talked about
that but he said that it stood for
something else so he didn't even like
know what the [ __ ] he was talking about
he didn't know [ __ ] can't even know
like real occult [ __ ]
he was just like pulling stuff out of
his ass he didn't know [ __ ] Crowley's
[ __ ] school right so so this is the
guy that they're - I want to call
Crowley's school the school that wasn't
well you know it's it's a school and
this Rowley was pulling out of his ass -
most [ __ ] well see that's the nice thing
about all that kind of occult stuff you
do pulls out of your ass and just like
make a whole [ __ ] industry out of that
[ __ ] yeah I see you know I respect the
Crowley was the prototype I probably was
the prototype for [ __ ] Scientology -
like who don't know that yeah he was
yeah Hubbard was like Hubbard was big
into that you know cuz Crowley realized
that people would pay money to become a
wizard yeah you could move him through
[ __ ] levels a study and keep him
going forever and make money off of them
yeah well that's that's all the bridge
is in Scientology you just keep yeah
you're sure making people pay you for
like a magic path I'm moti eight you
know or whatever and if they get enough
into it and they pay enough into it they
will legit think that they yeah I mean
look look at Tom Cruise he thinks he has
magic powers because hey you keep you
keep telling them that you tell them
that and it is and like I said since
they've already sunk like thousands and
thousands of dollars in it they don't
want to go back on it go man what a
[ __ ] I was they just there's like yeah
I've [ __ ] super have magic power see
although you know okay if you look at
Scientology we're going off I'm going
off on a [ __ ] tan are you guys on the
tangent look at Scientology each thing
the Scientology it would you go through
those OT levels there's not much there
yeah I mean yeah it really does it's all
[ __ ] normal human abilities and just
[ __ ] kind of a lot of it playing mind
games yeah it doesn't really get
bullshitty until you start telling
people that you can transcend space and
time and prevent accidents and the
reason why you haven't been in a car
accident is because the car accident
happened but you [ __ ] went backwards
in time to prevent it see if that's
winning yes because there's no great way
to prove that's proof that all right
they're like oh if you hadn't been a
[ __ ] OT [ __ ] seven or eight or
nine you would have been dead you'd have
been dead right now because all those
times you were driving the car you
actually had car accidents but you
[ __ ] stop time and went back and
[ __ ] like I said it's genius so
there's no way to [ __ ] really Tom
Cruise does have abilities the [ __ ] can
[ __ ] fly aircraft he's pretty good
with a gun he could [ __ ] did that
[ __ ] on his own right he learned how to
do it later in prison
millions of people learn to do that
stuff you don't have to be a Tod little
Tom's out there listen to me I respect
Tom [ __ ] he's a good actor we pick on
top I pick on top he's a good actor he
does have real skills okay yeah and yeah
I'm not saying that he should be proud
of his skills he actually can't do that
[ __ ] did Scientology give that to him no
I don't think so well like I said
because there's millions of people that
can do that that weren't Scientologists
they just did it because they wanted to
and they learned how to do it I think
Scientology gave Tom the the confidence
to go do that yeah I think I think he
wanted to be part of something and and
and and he doesn't get this [ __ ] sienten
know he got like this just your regular
people yeah he'll get [ __ ] on like
within the [ __ ] slavey everything
yeah he was poster boy they gave him the
best Scientology could offer yeah so for
him it worked out which I you know I can
get that cuz he's super privileged you
have like you know money and they kind
of and when you look at Scientology what
they're talking about it is it's a
[ __ ] self-esteem course yeah that's a
lot of it
I think but like I said you know anyone
can learn to I mean if I really wanted
to learn to fly a plane I could learn to
fly a plane right I mean you know what I
mean and this is something that and I
think I mentioned this to somebody like
in the YouTube comments when I think we
were talking about hoarders because I
was talking about my grandfather and my
grandfather one of the things he was a
hoarder and stuff like that he was also
a genius and one of the things that he
instilled in me and also in my mom and
all of her sisters and stuff like that
was if someone else learned to do it you
can too
yeah that was what he always if you have
a decent IQ there are some people that
know well yeah that's not true for
everybody but you know I mean you know
if you are a reasonably intelligent
person with reasonably intelligent at
least if you're at least average IQ
maybe a little bit yeah they will help
you if you want to do it bad enough you
can learn to do it like other people
have learned to do it then so can you
I want to have about 110 IQ if you have
110 IQ you [ __ ] you're good to go
yeah if you have 145 IQ it's even
[ __ ] better if you start getting past
145 IQ it's actually a hinderance tell
me about it yeah the smell it gets to a
point to where [ __ ] and there's
diminishing returns and all of a sudden
high intelligence work starts starts
working against you you start
overthinking things you suffered too
much and you start to malfunction
this was actually [ __ ] proven the
u.s. army proved it World War two
battlefield commanders when the IQs went
above 145 you started to fail they
started actually have [ __ ] defeats
and combats that have victories it's
because they over thought the enemy yeah
yeah no it's a yeah it's a problem yeah
you know because it starts to [ __ ]
verge on what do they call it
Asperger's it starts to disguise it I'm
not judging because it starts to start
going to where you start talking about
autism you know and I mean super high
Intel intellect is good for to solve
certain problems but it's not a
generalized intelligence a lot of times
that's the districts yeah it depends on
the thing it's like that's the thing
it's kind of complicated when you're
talking about intelligence because there
isn't really one kind of
intelligence there's a lot of bunch of
kinds right um the kind that they test
is generally I mean at least when I I
took an IQ test like a child
psychologist gave me an IQ test you know
many many years ago that is mostly a
test of logic and problem solving skills
yeah and I was technical yeah and in
which case when I was tested for that my
IQ was 152 however um you know other
things I have problems yeah
my IQ tested out at 145 all right that
was when I was young it's probably
declined some all right but really my
skills are what's called human
engineering skills I know how to deal
with people I can set Jenni will tell
you if I see you and talk to you
I can size you up I can find out
everything about you and I can make you
friend or foe or I can manipulate you or
I know when you're a threat Jenni will
tell you yeah I know I know bad when I
see it
[ __ ] what's a good way to put this for
me I focus on what's called you know
human engineering yeah relationships
with other people and systems and the
powers of Nostradamus and and no sir
Thomas's ability to foresee the future
is to understand human nature and and
understand how groups work and how and
how groups in inter interact with each
other so my ability to see the future
has to do with being able to [ __ ]
know how one group will interact with
another and how that [ __ ] will affect
the world that's how I that's how I
[ __ ] foresaw the apocalypse I tend to
be better at technical thing yeah she is
and she's real good at creative stuff
little technical stuff problem solving
specific problems there's a lot of
different kinds of intelligence there's
also people that are [ __ ] just
geniuses of [ __ ] physicality which I
respect like I said that's a totally
different I definitely legitimate kind
of intelligence I feel like that's one
they
test drive like I was good at the one
that they do test you're right but that
doesn't mean that that's the only kind
there are people that are just [ __ ]
physically just [ __ ] geniuses
athletes of different kind of different
types people that can [ __ ] just render
another person help us physically people
who can just overcome things physically
and you know there's no test for that
other than just sports I've seen it
happen and see that is one thing that
I'm not very good like it's weird
because I used to be really good at that
kind of thing like I used to be really
coordinated I used to do ballet stage
gymnastics at Olive's and then like
after my teenage years for some reason
that ability kind of went away and I got
like really klutzy and clumsy and I'm
not really sure why I don't know if it
was because cuz I had a lot of problems
my later confidence it might be that or
it might be I had a lot of problems with
my inner ears in my so it might be some
kind of balance issue because I have I
can't like I try to hold things and drop
them and run into walls I'm iris pecked
all different kinds of intelligence and
IQ but I'm big into human engineering
and physicality I love that you know I
respect athletes and people that are
physically endowed in certain ways and
genetics and then I'm [ __ ] big into
[ __ ] just the way people are and the
way they act and the way they think I'm
more into that I'm not into this little
technical stuff and you know I mean it's
just it's just not me other people are
into that yeah I'm into the application
you know I mean how do you take
knowledge apply it on to the [ __ ]
earth to make a world that you want you
know and that's really what human
engineering is all about yeah the guys
that are running the show are doing what
I'm talking about yeah they know how to
[ __ ] make the world bend to them
because they understand the systems and
they understand people yeah some people
would call it OS manipulation no that's
[ __ ] life well everything everybody
everything is manipulation and that's
the way it is you know manipulation of
some types has a bad rap as you know
understandably so and as it should but I
mean pretty much your whole entire life
you're trying to get people to do what
you want so you can move ahead in some
way or yeah and that's not necessarily a
bad thing it's just a human thing you
know politics its politics yeah that's
just how it is right you can see it
happening today but but yeah so we were
talking about Dale Griffiths these
supposed occult expert yes so like all
the [ __ ] that he came up with on the
stand just completely and even though
like from my point of view just saying I
didn't sit through the entire trial
obviously because you know I wasn't
there but just the portions of it that I
saw it seemed like the defense attorney
was doing pretty good at making this guy
look like a knob and just saying this
like look you don't you just bought this
[ __ ] degree you don't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] but here you are being a [ __ ]
occult experts because I guess everyone
can do that now but um it didn't really
seem to matter like to the juries
because they I figure the people in the
jury
they were firm around there it's I feel
like a lot of people had already made up
their minds you know what I mean that
these kids they look weird there you
know they listened to Metallica they
[ __ ] like I said they write bad goth
poetry like like we all did back in the
day and so because they are different
than us than they are outsiders and
therefore they must have done this
because they didn't want to think that
it was one of them or like just one of a
normal person even though I suspect that
it probably was they always want to like
have it be the other you know what I
mean so they can make that person into a
monster so another another point of
contention was that the prosecution
argued that Damien Echols knew stuff
about the case that had not been
released to the public and I'm doing air
quotes again this was the fact that one
of the victims Christopher Byers had
been more mutilated than the others they
was talking about the genital mutilation
now it is true that that wasn't
officially released to the public
however allegedly it had gotten out
through the rumor mill because
apparently one of the I believe one of
the maybe Christopher Byers stepfather
or mother or something like that had
been talking to the police in the case
and they knew the details of the case
and so it had kind of like spread
through the community like I said it's a
small town so I feel like he could have
heard that elsewhere like a
said there and there was a lot of [ __ ]
about police interrogations not just of
Jessie Misskelley but of all three of
the suspects that were suspiciously not
recorded by the police so it was kind of
became a case of these three teenage
boys and it was like a he-said she-said
because they would come out in court and
being like hey the cop said this that in
the other and then the cop would come on
the stands be like that's not what I
said but it wasn't recorded so no one
could check you know what I'm saying and
so I feel like the cops you know I you
know it's like I hate to say but in this
situation I really do feel like they had
decided that these kids were guilty
before any of this [ __ ] even happened
and they were just gonna make that
happen no matter what because of their
prejudices and yeah I believe that these
kids were guilty
from day one they didn't think and most
of the town did as well
I mean like I said if you see these
they're not gonna suspect one of their
own they're gonna some kind of like I
said it's easier it's easier to say it's
that weird person yeah very similar to
the witch trials yeah way you pick a
[ __ ] that stands out good oh it
has to be him
well yeah cuz he and my guys and that
happened in the witch trials too it's
like oh that old lady oh she has a
disease or she's weird or something like
that
wait there it's very easy to other right
someone that's not the way [ __ ]
criminality work no not emotionally a
person who is just like you but there at
least that's how you get away or on the
surface yeah I'm always way more
suspicious than normal people like weird
looking somebody who's camouflaged yeah
exactly
so so it ended up even though the the
trial was kind of a circus and kind of
[ __ ] in my opinion both Damien
Echols and Jason Baldwin were convicted
of three counts of murder Jason Baldwin
was given life in prison and Damien
Echols was put on death row so he was on
death row now
I mean honestly not too long after cuz I
think that really the impetus for for
looking at the case anew and like maybe
suspecting that these kids might be
innocent didn't really come until a few
years after the murders it was 1996
and HBO had produced this documentary
like the first part of a documentary
called Paradise Lost and it kind of went
into the case and stuff and I think that
once that kind of gained popular because
a lot of people saw that and it was like
a really big deal and once people saw
that documentary there was just kind of
this steam rolling kind of thing where
everybody saw this and started to see it
as a horrible injustice and even in 1996
when the first part of it came out they
didn't really have evidence that came
out later that maybe was pointing to
another suspect but I do think that it
even in 1996 it appeared that even if
the boys had been guilty like from that
you know from the perspective of that
time period that they had clearly not
gotten a fair trial because the police
had already decided that they were
guilty and were you know trying to like
push it in that direction so even after
1996 a lot of celebrities started to get
involved and normally this everyone's
kind of like rolls their eyes and like
oh god celebrities are getting involved
but in this case I think it was a good
thing because not only they put money
they put their name their fame behind it
and it kind of like brought a lot of
more attention to it and ended up
getting a lot more attention brought to
the case that probably wouldn't have
otherwise so you got people like you
know it's like Johnny Depp got involved
Henry Rollins got involved Natalie
Maines from the Dixie Chicks she got
involved Peter Jackson the director
director of Lord the Rings he got
involved so it's like a lot of these
people saw this documentary and thought
this is you know it's horrible that
these three little boys were killed but
we don't think that these three
teenagers did it which means not only
that you [ __ ] over these three
teenagers but also that the real killer
is still running around so they started
like giving money to the defense and
like speaking out doing benefit
conference concerts and stuff like that
now you know as the years went on and
these poor you know teenagers were like
[ __ ] rotting in jail and people
started looking more into the case there
was a really good book about it called
The Devil's knot where you know the the
author kind of like went into the
details behind the case that there was
some really like messed up [ __ ] behind
this case that didn't come out until
later on one the
crime scene was drastically compromised
like you know as I said before they you
know people were just like trampling all
over it they didn't really secure it in
a timely fashion the bodies were taken
out of the water before the coroner
arrived the coroner did not arrive until
two hours after the bodies had been
found and they were just like letting
the bodies like lay there on the bank
and they were like decaying like maggots
were eating them and stuff like that
which is not really a protocol they also
didn't drain the creek which is normally
what she would do in that situation so
you could like gather more evidence and
stuff like that also the you know the
guy that did the autopsies his expertise
was also called in a question like I
said because he initially um you know I
don't know if he came out and said that
the boys had been raped like I said
later on they determined that they had
not um but he also never tested the the
blood that was found at the scene which
wasn't a lot because like I said they
don't think that the boys were
necessarily killed at that location they
might have been brought there from
somewhere else
but even the little bit of blood that
they found there was never tested they
also didn't it just seems like the the
coroner he said that the genitals of I
believe it was Christopher Christopher
Byers were cut off with a knife and that
the there were scratch wounds and stuff
and like I said if you watch the
documentaries they'll show you that like
pictures and stuff like that and it's
you know it's kind of upsetting so just
letting you know ahead of time but there
were these like weird scratches on there
which he said had been done with a
hunting knife now there was another
weird thing to where this hunt there
there was a hunting knife found in a
lake behind one of the suspects houses
and at the trial they made a huge deal
about this as though this was the murder
weapon however as they later discovered
when when other liked experts other
coroner's and stuff like that looked
into this case they were like the wounds
that you're seeing on these bodies that
was not a knife
and it came out later that allegedly
that knife had actually
been thrown into that lake before the
murders even happened the old ass knife
yes so it's like and there was nothing
tying any of the suspects to the Knights
they didn't know if it was belonged to
any of them and one journalist that I
was listening to who covered the case
from who lived there and he covered the
case from the thing he's like you know
the cops had called us before they even
found this knife and called us and said
hey we're gonna find something today you
guys need to come out there and cover it
so it's almost like they knew that it
was in there and like I said it was
never determined that it was the murder
weapon but they they almost kind of made
it at the trial seemed like it was the
murder weapon without coming out and
saying that it was the murder weapon but
it didn't have anything to do with the
case like I said it was just some old
knife that they found and that they they
couldn't tie to any of the suspects they
couldn't ID the victims or nothing and
as I said later they they found out that
like the scratches and stuff because
what they tried to imply at the trial
was that that was that one of these
three teenagers had taken this hunting
knife you know the kind of serrated
knife and had like scraped it like down
the because they weren't stabbed like I
said and it like scraped it down there
you know down there skinned and later
experts that looked into it said you
know look that looks like an animal
pretty so that's like turtle claws and
they said that might be the same is you
know and they I think they consulted
like six different uh you know
pathologists later on and showed them
photos and like some of them I think
we've got to examine the actual bodies
and they said you know the the one whose
genitals were mutilated they said that
looks like a turtle that's what I said
yeah that's why I was like yeah that was
a good that you uh well being having a
[ __ ] country background I understand
about Mississippi if it's in the whole
[ __ ] water the turtles go right after
it
it's [ __ ] snapping turtles and in um
in the newer documentary west of Memphis
they actually went to a turtle expert
who lived in the area and he's like look
the creek where these boys bodies were
found it was like turtle central they
even called it Turtle Creek turtle
something and these turtles have that
really sharp beak they're big and he's
like and he put
like a pig carcass in the water he's
like they will go after little fleshy
bits like ears testicles
you know penises anything that's
dangling there in the water oh yeah
their mouths are like little snips yep
they're like they're just like a little
aluminum snips they'll take take little
pieces out and they're everywhere and
they're their friendly little creatures
just don't [ __ ] put your hand in
front of them yeah they're just like
finger yeah yeah but yeah so it does
seem like the coroner in the initial
investigation so so all the [ __ ] about
oh the genital mutilation and that means
it's a satanic calls and stuff ended up
probably being [ __ ] because they
said you know all of the other experts
they consulted later on that like some
of the celebrities that got involved in
the case they like actually put their
own money into like hiring these other
people and we're like I don't know why
anyone would think that that had been
done by a person and had been done
before the kids were dead because that
is clearly postmortem
and that appears to be animal predation
oh yeah and that would have happened in
that because like I said even in the
documentary because I was looking you
know I'm looking at the photo in the
video and stuff like that of them
actually bringing the bodies like out of
the creek and it's like the bodies it's
it's you know it's horrific because
they're dead and they're naked and
everything like that but they didn't
look like they had been cut up or
stabbed or ritualistic alee it's
mutilated or anything like that it's
funny because you would think you would
think that these [ __ ] up here
that they would know better because I
think they did know unique country boy
knows I think they did it that's in the
[ __ ] water it's food yep everything's
eating on that fish turtles you know so
I ain't buying that they knew I think
they knew to date day but have to know
like I said I think they had a party
Nick at nature decided yeah they don't
because it's second nature for a
southerner who's [ __ ] rural to
understand that if it's in the [ __ ]
water the turtles are eating it yeah I
mean they're [ __ ] everywhere and like
I said they even knew there were
everywhere in this [ __ ] Creek yeah
and the kids were in there for like 24
hours and - maybe not 24 hours but like
at least 12 hours in the water they know
when somes
if it's not moving as dead they're gonna
get a bite off that yeah and they're
gonna go for the [ __ ] softest bits
that are sticking out first that's
exactly what happens yeah and like I
said every single expert like
independent expert that they hired later
on was like I don't see how anyone could
have thought that a person right did
that right like cut it off with a knife
because that is clearly like a turtle
they're just trying to pin it on
somebody yeah and so like I said they're
honestly at that point I think there was
like no excuse because I think they did
know so I mean it would be different if
they had pulled the kids out of the
water and there had been like [ __ ]
pentagrams like carved into their chest
or something like that but it's like the
injuries that they had were not
consistent with what they were trying to
make you know it's funny I don't know
the main suspect cuz you haven't
mentioned him yet I don't know this much
about the case at this point I would say
that [ __ ] just tying some kids up not
do anything to them and throw them in
the water it almost sounds like
something a [ __ ] child would do it's
the [ __ ] suspect young no no okay
nope why the [ __ ] would somebody do this
uh yeah here's the motive that's weird
about it it's like even though I have my
suspicions about who did it it's like I
I'm not sure intact well I would think
if there were a sexual motive there
besides a [ __ ] sexual assault yeah
the weird thing about it is they brought
in um John Douglas the FBI profiler very
famous you know you know he was one of
the ones that started the FBI profiling
hold division and they brought him in
and when he was first looking at the
scene he's like I mean even initially
this guy said this does not look like a
crime committed by three dumb teenagers
this looks like one person and this
looks like a lust murder now after they
came you know they they had more
forensic evidence and stuff like that
he's like maybe not less murder but he's
like a personal murder this is somebody
that knew at least one he's like that
knew at least one of these boys and
maybe the other two were just collateral
damage that's what he said and I'm kind
of thinking that that's probably what
this issue is you know what I mean
that's what I'm saying so there was
another thing too that there was
something okay one thing that went
around was that one of the boys
had urine in their stomachs which again
was like another thing that went around
trying to pursue they made him drink pee
or something like that
which one one that was also [ __ ]
like whoever that was just like a rumor
and also that they they consulted a
doctor and it darhk's like what is that
that is not even that wouldn't even
happen like because even if you drank
urine it would just like soak back into
your [ __ ] they wouldn't find urine in
your stomach you know what I'm saying
he's like that's just that wouldn't
happen after that time period there was
also like some [ __ ] going around where
Damien had like human testicles like in
his house or stuff like that which was
also [ __ ] but still like I said it
just seemed like this whole witch-hunt
atmosphere now another thing that went
around was that some of the bodies had
bite marks on them now whether these
were actually human bite marks or not
has never been definitively determined
however most experts have said even if
they are human bite marks which they
doubt um none of the bite marks match
any of the three suspects because the
three suspects did indeed have their
teeth they did all that comparison and
stuff so like we're not even sure those
are human bite marks on the bodies they
might be just barked and marks sort of
like animal marks or whatever but even
if they are human bite marks they're not
from any of those three
so May of 1994 all three defendants
you know appealed the convictions but
they convictions were all upheld now
something that came out I believe this
was in 2007 okay so because you know
when this trial first took place in the
early 90s you know they I guess they had
DNA but it wasn't real you know up to
the minute or anything like that so in
2007 they decided to retest some of the
evidence now they found a hair that was
intertwined in the shoelace that had
been used to tie one of the boys up
which suspicious this hair was um
genetically very similar
to the stepfather of one of the boys
Terry Hobbs interestingly Terry Hobbs
was also according to at least one
possibly two witnesses the last person
to see the kids like a couple neighbors
had seen the boys like two of them on
the bikes and one of them on the
skateboard had seen Terry Hobbs walking
toward them and like calling them hey
it's time to come home blah-dee-blah he
was the stepfather of Stevie branch
actually so he was kind of like
according to several witnesses he was
the last person to be seen like walking
toward them or near them or whatever one
of his hairs was found in the knot of
one of the shoelaces that had been used
to kill to tie the boys up now could
this be secondary transfer because he
was you know lived in the house with one
of them sure however they found another
bit of physical evidence he was her hair
or some DNA or something like that at
the scene like not tied up in the knots
or anything like that
now this evidence was a genetic match to
another guy named David Jacoby David
Jacoby was not only a friend of Terry
Hobbs
he was also Terry Hobbs alibi for the
time of the murder
now I'm not coming out and saying that
Terry Hobbs was the killer
but um the only physical evidence that
they found at the scene kind of points
to him and the fact that he had an alibi
that oh him and David Jacoby were out
looking for the boys at the time when
they were supposedly murdered and both
of their evidence like physical evidence
that it's genetically similar to both of
them was found at the crime scene that
seems a little fishy to me I'm just
saying now Natalie Maines of the Dixie
Chicks she actually came out and said
that she thought that mother [ __ ] did
it and he tried to sue her and he lost
for saying that well you know like so
because she's a First Amendment right
see what she wants right yeah so there
was like some other [ __ ] too but they
didn't the
about it is that they interviewed like a
couple of the other parents cuz like I
said 50% of the time at least 50% of the
time when a kid dies the parent has
something to do with it 50% that's what
I've heard so the fact that they didn't
interview this guy I believe they
interviewed a couple of the other like
John Mark Byers Christopher Byers
stepfather I believe they interviewed
him at the time and like I said he's the
one that kind of came off a little bit
like a crazy person like in the first
Paradise Lost documentary from 1986 but
has later like said that you know he's
sorry that he was portrayed that way and
he actually came out later and said that
he thought that the West Memphis Three
were innocent but they didn't but the
cops didn't interview Terry Hobbs until
many years later now it seems like you
would interview the parents first
because that's usually I mean
statistically that's something you
should be doing I mean if you knew what
you were doing because like I said most
of the time when you get killed it's
somebody you know right somebody of your
family so the fact that they didn't
interview him even though according to
like allegedly he had been abusive to
Stevie branch he had um you know he was
not a really sis stepdad not his real
dad um so there had been like a history
there so it could have been I'm not
saying like I said I'm not I don't know
if he did it he might have nothing to do
with it I don't know it I'm just saying
it looks kind of suspicious that his
[ __ ] physical evidence was there and
his friends you know and also alibis
like physical evidence was also found at
the scene that seems a little strange
and it also seems strange that like a
witness saw him walking toward them like
not long before they disappeared I don't
know if he if he did kill them I don't
think he intended to kill them I just
think he was like maybe going after them
and they got into an argument or
something like that and then maybe he
did it accidentally and then he thought
well maybe I just need to get rid of
these other two just because they're
[ __ ] witnesses or whatever I'm not
sure entirely what happened cops are not
entirely sure what happened because like
I said no one's they're not even really
sure if the kids were killed there or if
they were killed somewhere else and then
taken to that spot because like I said
there was no
there was hardly any blood at the scene
or no indication that anything had taken
place there so because there was not
that much physical evidence they're not
even really sure where the murder took
place but there's some other kind of
fishy [ __ ] about Terry Hobbs too like
some some people have said not only was
he seen like walking toward them but
there was another witness who lived in
the house that also said that he was
doing laundry at like a weird time which
seemed strange like they noticed it
because they said he never did laundry
ever so it seemed weird for him to be
like washing clothes and sheets and
stuff like that it like some weird time
in the morning or whatever so there is
some evidence to suggest that perhaps
one of the kids stepfathers was
responsible however like I said it's
allegedly allegedly and no charges have
been brought against him I did see that
they the cops finally interviewed him
later on and he you know denies having
anything to do with the crime but he
seems a little um he seems a little
evasive I mean from my in my opinion he
seems a little vasive I don't know a lot
of people do think that probably he's
the guy they should be looking at um but
you know I'm not gonna go there and say
that I think he did it or anything like
that because he might not have now so
these three teenagers who you know are
now grown men obviously they were in
prison for 18 years
like I said they did several appeals all
of which failed now the shitty thing was
that the appeal was overseen by the same
judge that had convicted them in the
first place
now this judge was the same guy who said
that he didn't think anyone would
falsely confess to anything which
obviously that's [ __ ] because people
do it all the time
he also seemed like when they came
forward in 2007 and it's like look we
have this new DNA evidence that points
to someone else like we did the hair
analysis and everything he almost seemed
like he just didn't want to [ __ ] deal
with it he was just like whatever I've
like dealt with this case for however
many years it was it's like you know
they're guilty blah blah blah so it
seemed like not I mean I think he kind
of had a change of heart later on but
when he was like looking into a feel
like he's like he wouldn't give them
new trial even though all this new
evidence had come out because he just
seemed like he was over it kind of yeah
so he actually left being a judge
because he got like elected to the
[ __ ] you know Senator Congress or
whatever the hell they get a you know
you know elected to so they replaced him
with someone else now the judge that
came in later on was more open to okay
let's see what we can do like to maybe
reopen the case or whatever so they were
going to reopen the case even though you
know they had all this new evidence that
seemed really strong but they were still
kind of afraid that you know they might
get convicted again and then there
really wouldn't be anything they could
do about it and I mean at this point
Damien Echols had been on death row and
like he was gonna [ __ ] die they were
just gonna [ __ ] kill him so they kind
of like all behind the scenes they all
kind of came to like you know lawyers
and judges and whatever they kind of
came to a thing they're like okay well
why don't we do this why don't we see if
we can get what they call an Alford plea
now I'm not really sure if you guys know
what this is it's kind of this weird
it's this really weird thing and I'm not
even really sure I need a [ __ ]
research we're like why this is even a
thing an Alford plea is essentially when
you're coming out saying okay I didn't
do this crime however I'm going to plead
guilty because I think that if I went to
trial I would be convicted of it so you
plead guilty even though you say you're
innocent but they'll let you go you know
what I mean so it's like this really
weird like legal they don't really do it
that often but in this case so they
approach the three of them and they said
okay well we have this thing where you
know do you want to do an Alford plea if
you do an Alford plea but all three of
you have to do it then you will be out
by the end of the week and like I said
they've been in there for 18 years
that's a weird ask how the hell yeah
it's very very rare ended but let us go
yeah kind of weird yeah basically what
it is it's it's I feel like a particular
in this case it was an ass covering
because I think at this point the
Arkansas police like everyone involved
in this case knew they [ __ ] up but
they didn't want to admit it so it's
like well this will give us a chance to
say that the case is closed
but they'll still be let out because
probably they didn't do it it was almost
kind of like a it's like face-saving
like you they can still get out but
they're still technically guilty and the
case is technically closed because
they're still guilty but they still get
to go free you know what I mean yeah so
like I said this is a very unusual move
so the lawyers were like well you know
maybe we can do this because by this
time you know all of these documentaries
had come out all these celebrities had
come out and raised all this money and
got their own you know experts they had
all this evidence that they you know
they brought in all these new experts
Peter Jackson Heep [ __ ] paid for like
six different like forensic tests and
like he paid like thousands and
thousands of dollars but he made the
documentary in West of Memphis because
he felt really strongly that these kids
were innocent and they really need to be
let out so they had all these people
pulling for them so finally you know
they were like okay so all three of you
if you come into court and this is what
you have to say you have to say like
look I didn't do this [ __ ] but I'm
pleading guilty because I am saying that
if you did bring me to trial again then
you have enough evidence to convict me
so I'm pleading guilty even though I
didn't do it so that's what they said
there now there's no guarantee that the
judge is gonna go okay you know what I
mean it's like no but if they say no
it's like you just go back to jail you
know what I mean now initially Damien
was like yeah man I'll just say whatever
the [ __ ] you want just let me the [ __ ]
out of here because at this point like
his health had really started to
deteriorate um you know he his his
eyesight is [ __ ] up because you know
he was on death row so it's like they
say you know legally you get one hour
and stuff he's like yeah they lead you
down from your cell into a slightly
bigger room and let you walk around he's
like I didn't go to get to go outside or
nothing like that so he was just like
staring at a wall for 24 hours a day so
his eyesight deteriorated he still has
to wear sunglasses now because he can't
he can't see any more real
it's like just our bright lights or
anything so so they so Damian says fine
I'll sign anything Jessie Misskelley
he's like yeah just fine just let me out
I'll do it now Jason Baldwin he didn't
want to do it because he said look I
would rather sit in here than say that
I'm guilty because I didn't do this [ __ ]
and I don't want everybody thinking I'm
guilty so he was like sticking to his
guns man like he was just like I would
rather sit in here until I'm dead then
say that I did this and I didn't do it
which you know I respected I respect
that
I really do and and that is another
thing that kind of makes me think that
they didn't do it because he was willing
to die in prison rather than say that he
[ __ ] did it you know what I'm saying
so so he wasn't gonna go along with it
but that was only for like a few days or
something because then like the lawyer
talking I was like look dude it's like
if you don't do this he's like I know it
sucks I know it's against your principle
well it wasn't even him he's like I know
you don't care about you but Damian is
going to die
he is going you know he's gonna get the
[ __ ] death penalty if you don't do
this you know please do it so they
finally talked him into it and in 2011
they let them out and I was watching an
interview with Damien Echols and he said
we didn't even really know that we were
gonna be let out until like the night
before they let us out he's like so it
was like the freakiest most surreal
because he's like we go in this room and
he's like we're still all shackled
together and stuff and he's like they
gave us this paper to read and I was
just like I didn't know he's like I
hadn't slept for like a week cuz I was
so worried about it because he because
like I said there's no guarantee that
the judge would be like okay you can do
that that's just a plea that you put in
they don't have to accept it so he's
like so I didn't know it was gonna
happen and I was like worried about he's
like oh [ __ ] what if they say no and I
have to come back in here and all this
other kind of crap so so they go in
there and he's like they they said okay
we are free to go and he's like then
they just unlock them and he's like I
didn't know what the [ __ ] he's like it
was the weirdest thing ever and it's
like they had this big party for them
because he had married since then he had
a wife named Laurie she was the last
she's a landscape architect and she had
been pulling for him like the whole
entire time I mean she visited him like
every [ __ ] time they could visit she
got she was the one
that like coordinated like all the you
know all the celebrities and everything
like that she talked to Peter Jackson
and Fran Walsh and all them and got like
all the money and got all raised all the
money for their defense and all this
other kind of stuff so she was there
listed they got married like in a
Buddhist ceremony and everything and she
was waiting for him when he got out and
um the funny thing was that so he gets
out and they immediately they moved to
New York City which is very funny I was
watching there was an interview it was
from 2018 I think and it was the New
York Public Library had put it on and
because Damien Echols wrote a book while
he was in prison called life after death
and it was like about his experience
like in prison and about what had
happened and everything and so he was
talking about that and he was talking
with Henry Rollins who like I said got
into the case like early on and kind of
was was like a big supporter and did
benefit conference concerts for them and
stuff to get them let out and um he's
like he's like I grew up in Arkansas and
I'd never been anywhere else and he's
like I thought I never thought that I
would like like New York City but he's
like I went there and he's just like I
thought it was amazing he's like I just
thought it was the best place ever so he
lived there him and his wife lived there
for a while I think since then they've
actually settled in Salem Massachusetts
which he thought was very funny because
of the whole like witch trial thing and
like what had happened with him and the
Salem of today is an Italian
neighborhood with it with him and two
other guys but well yeah but he's just
like he just thought it was funny
because of like the history and
everything and he's like that's kind of
how I was traded so I can kind of relate
so him and his wife I believe they live
in Salem now and they actually did have
like I said a lot of help a lot of
celebrities I got involved in like you
know helps them out when he got out of
jail because he'd been in jail since he
was a teenager so he didn't know how to
drive you didn't know anything about
anything you know the world had changed
so much since then and he's like and the
shitty thing is technically one of the
stipulations of the Alford plea and like
I said this is why this is like a state
ass-covering thing that Arkansas did was
that you can't sue them for wrongful
conviction damn that was another thing
no reparations no nothing and they are
still considered guilty so that's still
on his record so if anybody does like a
background check it's like guilty of a
triple homicide of eight year old boy
even though like I said 90% sure he
didn't do that [ __ ]
so that's on their record still so at
this point he's like look I'm kind of
like sick of you know having to do this
and like I'm gonna talk about it because
like but until we get exonerated and
like said that we're not guilty we're
still kind of gonna be [ __ ]
I hear cases like this man [ __ ] makes
you mad well a lot it makes a lot of
people mad
makes you wonder man just street justice
better than this then then this [ __ ]
court justice is that these
[ __ ] are hand out these old
podunk towns you know yeah that's I can
i'd like i'd rather have street justice
like i said i think that you know i
think that this is something that a lot
of people like why this case
particularly resonated with a lot of
people was because you know this is a
very backwards small town they don't
have on anything on these guys right no
[ __ ] forensic there's no clear
connection between these dudes and these
bodies yeah the forensic evidence they
found they they found nothing that
linked back to those things just she was
she different yeah just suspicious and
like i said it seemed like even from the
beginning and I mean Damien himself has
said this and like I said he's very
well-spoken he's very you know he's a
lot more chill about it than I would be
like I said it must be some Buddhist
[ __ ] because I would be like really
really super mad blowing their [ __ ] up
that's what I mean well I mean he's
basically came on it he loved New York
City's like he lives in Salem
Massachusetts now as far as I know but
he said you know I really don't want to
ever go back to Arkansas and it's like
man Oh [ __ ] blame you because look
what the [ __ ] they did to him and he's
like it was the whole he's like it just
seemed like the whole thing was they
were just like railroaded from the
beginning you know were they all like
you know troubled kids sure like some of
them had been in trouble for other
things nothing major not murder not
anything like that some really bring
that matters she's a chef [ __ ]
physical evidence exactly there's some
kind of [ __ ] witness testimony there
wasn't even that and even the witness
testimony that they had I mean the
shitty thing was that and you can see
this on some of the documentaries like I
said that one Vicki Hutcheson woman she
later came out and said yeah I made
everything up there was another guy that
um that had done like some
juvenile detention time with damien
echols and he came out on the stand and
he was saying that that Damien had told
him that he's like oh I get power by
drinking blood and have you know boys
penises and I put their balls in my
mouth and stuff and like I said you can
see it's on the documentary and that kid
also he was a teenager also he later
came out and said that he made it all up
of course everybody recanted like all
the [ __ ] that they like all the Satanic
[ __ ] stories they had all the oh I
saw him at a [ __ ] Sabbath or whatever
all of those people came out later and
said yeah I made it all up or the police
told me I could get reward money or I
could do this and that so it really does
seem like this is a case of the cops
deciding that oh well this guy looks a
little bit weird so he must be a
Satanist so he must have done this and
everything was engineered to get that
get to that end goal yeah this [ __ ] here
was done by somebody just from the town
that's all like I said I suspect and
even like you know the FBI profiler was
like this looks like a personal murder
it's like you know there was no rape
there was no nothing like that so it
wasn't like a serial killer how do you
have something personal against an
eight-year-old though that's why I
suspect it was maybe a family member
yeah because I mean and the thing about
it and like I said I'm not saying
anybody in particular don't sue me I'm
just saying that step parent step
parents um you know killing the children
of their you know significant other that
is rid of them that is not uncommon um
you know what I mean so it is very it's
actually quite common you know in these
kind of blended families for step
parents to eliminate the children of
their you know I'm just saying I'm not
saying that that's what happened I'm
just saying that all the physical the
very little physical evidence that they
found at the scene points to completely
different people than these three people
like I said there are still people and
interestingly two of the families of the
murdered boys flipped and they later
said yeah we don't think the
West Memphis Three are guilty even
though they did at the time they were
super pissed off about they wanted to
kill him and all this other kind of
stuff so no it's on the documentary but
two of the families later came around
you know and said yeah no I think they
were railroaded and that's really sucks
the one the Moore family I think they're
still kind of holding out that they
think that the West Memphis Three are
probably still guilty but I mean
according to like the [ __ ] that I
watched with Damien Echols and Henry
Rollins Henry Rollins said that he had
spoken to the mother of Michael Moore I
think her name's Dana and he's like look
I'm not trying to like you know make you
mad I'm not trying to say you know that
I got so behind this case and I
hopefully and and he's like she was
really pretty cool about it
so she even kind of said I'm not really
sure anymore so you know even like um
they they've even done I saw like a
fairly recent like you know half an hour
like news report where they kind of went
around like man in the street and they
were asking people in West Memphis
Arkansas nowadays like if they thought
then most people thought that they
probably were not guilty and that they
had been railroaded so you can see how
over the years you know and I think the
documentaries really helped in that
regard kind of made people change their
tune a little bit and like I said we've
come a long way since 1993 um you know
even though like I said I was out of
high school by that time so but I still
remember there was still these pockets
of satanic panic [ __ ] and it's like
like I said Damien Echols didn't even
look all that weird Jason Baldwin didn't
look all that weird he just had the kind
of a blond mullet he had a Metallica
shirt he just looked like a [ __ ]
teenager man that's what they all looked
like you know they they made a big deal
about Damien Echols oh he had the book
of shadows he had like a note book that
he wrote [ __ ] in and they were asking
him about at the trial like a lot of the
[ __ ] that he wrote and there was just
like Metallica lyrics and some of the
[ __ ] was from Shakespeare and stuff like
that so it's like they're trying to make
him look like evil incarnate and I was
like he was just like a [ __ ] goth kid
man it was like everybody did that [ __ ]
you know so I like I said I think that's
why it resonates with a lot of people
particularly people like Henry Rollins
and stuff like that because
you know people who look different in a
small town like that and how you kind of
get [ __ ] on you kind of get suspected of
everything you know particularly back in
those days but this is a really extreme
case where he actually ended up losing
18 years of his life on death row as you
know and you know the other two kids too
also 18 years of their life gone just
because essentially because of how they
looked which is pretty [ __ ] up but
yeah so you done you look like you'd
yeah yeah we're actually recording this
a little bit earlier you know I got a
warm-up coming cuz we got oh boy yeah
I'm surprised like Pookie hasn't come in
here like put her button the camera
sleeping in the boat she's taking a nap
like I said we're recording this a
little bit earlier than usual it's not
evening it's like actually late
afternoon what we're drinking anyway cuz
why not it's [ __ ] Friday but yeah so
we're gonna whip this [ __ ] we're gonna
wrap up this show about West Memphis
Three hope you guys have enjoyed it I'm
sure we'll get some entertaining
comments about this one cuz like I said
this is one that has a lot of really a
passionate viewpoints on both sides so
we'll see how that goes but until next
time remember if you like the show
please like share subscribe on all your
social media if you would like to
financially support the show we have a
patreon patreon calm slash 13 o'clock
podcast or if you'd like to give a
one-time PayPal donation that would also
be much appreciated you go to our blog
13 o'clock podcast dot WordPress comm
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account and be sure you
separate they're just cracking it yeah
and that'll do it for episode 199 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]